welcome everybody to the speed Chess
Championship 2021 and really it's the
birthday special Donya happy birthday my
friend
thank you Robert I I appreciate it I'm
hitting that spot where I'm not quite as
keen on birthdays anymore but I could
think of no better present uh than to
commentate a speed chess championship
match up with you so thank you Robert
and uh great to be here although it is
just a tiny bit early on the west coast
just 351 but yeah
I would you know this is the only thing
I would wake up for I was going to say
that if I'm going to wake up this early
for your birthday celebration that's
what it's all about but we do have some
big news to announce before we even talk
about today's matchup it's the fact that
alireza faruja has withdrawn from the
speed Chess Championship but don't be
disappointed because we have a superstar
replacing him at the two seed with an
asterisk that is Ricard report from
Hungary the absolute Legend one of the
most unpredictable players in the World
dania I know you're a fan of his play
what do you have to say about report and
entering the field
indeed it's definitely sad that Perugia
will not be joining us for the SEC but
it's not one of those things Robert
where you have you know LeBron James
being replaced by some benchwarmerhead
report is is an absolute Beast I've
modeled a lot of my opening repertoire
uh on his he is an incredibly
enterprising tactical player and I think
he has every chance to go far in the SEC
so uh be kudos to chess.com for finding
a replacement on the Fly and what a
replacement it is as he's going to face
Alexi Serena on Wednesday November 10th
uh in his first trial I'm super excited
for this I am as well but I'm probably
even more excited for the matchup we're
about to see but that's just because
it's imminent and it is ding liren in
Shakira mamajaro so we have a great
match up ahead of us today Dania I'm
stoked for it
I guess we should remind everybody what
the format is because before we get into
the greatness of these two players we
should tell everybody what's at stake
here what the format's going to be like
it is that 90 minutes of five plus one
Blitz followed by an hour of three plus
one we get the 30 minutes of one plus
one bullet and if we're treated to a tie
break oh that's the best birthday
present you could possibly get it
absolutely is and if this match is going
to be anything like uh the inaugural SEC
matchup yesterday then we might very
well be in for a tie break uh
yesterday's match didn't hit the tie
break but it came pretty darn close and
these players as we're gonna see uh are
very very close in strength and taking a
look at this bracket that is just
mouth-watering Robert nothing to say
here but to just drop your jaw in awe at
some of these matchups and if we look if
we look at the bracket here you see
dingley Ren and Mama jar of in the
bottom left hand side of the screen they
have a good chance against the winner of
Aaron Yan and dubov all these players
are superstars there's no target in the
field everyone is so talented and can
beat another on any given day but that
bottom side of the field there I think
is pretty wide open so I'm very curious
to see who makes it on top today
indeed and obviously the person with the
biggest X on his back isikara Nakamura
uh he's going to be facing off against
Peter svidler in the first round
but as you said anybody can win this
tournament everybody's so incredibly
talented and that's what gives I think
the SCC It's Magic there are no
walkovers there are no easy matches for
anybody and this is certainly not an
easy match for either of the players
involved no it's not we're spoiled we
have dingly Wren shock we are mama jarv
I am especially curious to see dingley
ran play because he's been pretty quiet
during the pandemic hasn't taken part in
the over-the-board tournaments uh you
know there are of course uh it's we
would love to see him play in these
events but what do you make of that like
a over-the-board absence will that play
a part in this match because shocker and
marmad he himself did sit out of the
recently concluded Grand Swiss so what
do you make of that
yeah I mean I think comparatively
speaking uh both players have been
relatively quiet recently but shocker
has uh had a greater footprint I think
in coveted era online tournaments than
ding ding did have that string of
tournaments where he really really
struggled uh both over the board uh
during the candidates and online in some
of these rapid tournaments so I think
that you know to to paraphrase Mark
Twain uh news of dingler and slump have
been greatly exaggerated I think he's
still an amazing player and I think he's
going to be very eager uh to show that
he can still deliver a a very powerful
batch and again I would not I would not
bat an eye if he goes very far in the
SEC no I wouldn't be surprised at all
and well we're eager for this match to
begin we're going to take a very short
break and in return it will be the start
of dingley Ren and chakra of here the
speeches championship
foreign
[Music]
or learn how to improve join us at the
number one chess destination in the
world chess.com
the thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
and we return ready for this exciting
matchup between dingley Ren and chakra
mamajarov Donnie I can't lie to you I am
so so excited
I'm incredibly excited too and you know
how can you not be there's an NBA
announcer I think for the Sacramento
Kings always says you know if you didn't
like that play you don't like NBA
basketball well guess what if you're not
excited for this match then I think
chess is not for you Mama Yara and
dingley Wren playing three plus hours of
Blitz what could be better than that not
much but let's talk about the
predictions for this because I always
put my co-comp there on the spot it's
your birthday I'm not treating you any
differently you can cry if you want to
but you're still gonna have to make a
prediction okay what do you think here
do you think that these are accurate is
chakra the slight favorite
I think that yeah I mean look I think
5347 you can talk semantics here I think
something along the lines of 50 50 is
very reasonable I would give shock a
little bit of an edge because he's been
more active and I think most people
probably in the chat are more familiar
with shocker yards Blitz Mastery I think
ding is kind of an unknown I'm actually
not too familiar Robert with ding's uh
Blitz play and with his bullet play so I
definitely agree with the idea of giving
shock a small Edge but absolutely
anything can happen so that was
basically a non-answer as usual but you
did put me on the spot and I normally
it's my birthday so I don't have to
answer any questions that's very fair
well I am very excited as well I think
that it should be a close matchup and I
also don't have a clue about the bullet
and it's any given day things can change
I get the sense that Mama jar should be
the slight favorite especially in the
quicker time controls but dingley Ren is
an absolute Powerhouse that people have
probably forgotten a bit about simply
because he has not been playing that
much chess but he will not be forgetting
how the pieces move he knows how to
shine and even in the candidates right
the first half he was not in his best
form the second half he was beating
players left and right he beat Jana
palmistry in the final round and here we
go
and I would I would argue also that the
way that he plays he's so incredibly
solid he's versatile and that translates
really well to the context of a match he
doesn't get too high with the highs
doesn't get too low with the lows he
just keeps that water spout running and
that kind of War of Attrition type play
can be incredibly hard to deal with in a
match H4 in the king's inning which has
become Robert an incredibly popular
weapon I mean everybody's playing this
now
they are and you know Peter swidler he
is the expert in the grunfeld leading
expert and he's faced the kind of H4
moves very early and look at this one I
like C6 because it's clear you want to
strike with D5 and capture back with the
pawn when someone attacks on the flank
you often want to attack in the center
and then dingley runs suddenly plays
Bishop F4 and turns it back into a
normal looking position with the move H4
thrown in so down here what is this
well this has now acquired the the
Contours of some sort of a jababa London
as ding prepares H5 oftentimes you'll
see H5 played Without Bishop E2 and
Mommy jarov could have also pushed his
own H Pawn but here he allows H5 he's
not too worried about that H file
getting open but black does have to uh
gin up some play on The Queen side you
can't fall asleep forever eventually
White's going to turn that H file into a
tangible attack but it's very important
Robert not to uh not to overestimate why
it's attacked and mate is not coming
anytime soon black has a couple of Tempe
maybe prepare E5 maybe go Queen B6 I
don't know yeah I kind of like the idea
of Queen B6 one thing that I would
consider is saying Bishop F5 to play
Knight E4 next but when white plays move
Pawn F2 to F3 then G4 will come with
Tempo my Bishop's on F5 so I'm origin
for right away what am I even talking
about it's like I can't why just push
forward and just keep the attack going
now he's decided not a completely
different approach this has caught me
off guard he's got H6 and he's gone
fully positional here he says okay I'm
not going to open the H file but what
I'm going to to do instead is fully
Heming this bishop and just pretend that
it's another day in the office well it's
not because he's got a Pawn on H6 and
now he's still Castle short this is
modern Chess at its best it's funny
though because when we think about
dingley Ren we think about this like
solid but ready to punch at any moment
exactly right from the start of this
game was throwing his Pawn up the board
and the reason why H6 is sort of you
know we're like why why that move was
played is that it closes the position it
releases the tension and in end games if
the Queens get traded that pawn H6 can
be a Target rather than a string so you
have to watch out that you don't go a
little too far because that pawn is
separated from the rest of the pack
indeed it is and here dig has a decision
on his hands that Knight on e4 can be
traded you can take on e4 and then black
will have a decision of whether or not
to take with the pawn or the bishop
Queen B3 also looks like a typical kind
of grunefully move that white plays in
these types of positions
ding's king is not in any real danger so
even though you've pushed that h-bun
forward that's not the problem I agree
with you I think the problem in the long
run for white is is to be really careful
not to abandon that H Pawn the more
pieces disappear off the board the
weaker that pawn becomes as you had
noted I like the queen B3 a lot because
it hits B7 hits D5 it sort of forces
Black's hand so putting the queen on B3
makes perfect sense there it is and if
the Knight caption C3 you just take back
with your Rook bring the next one to C1
and it's kind of like playing an
exchange slob and speaking of how
openings can transpose into one another
that's what the vibe I'm getting but
that pause on H6 which is just taking my
attention away from some of the other
parts of the board yet this seems to be
standard play yeah it's hard not to look
at the spawn I was contemplating as you
were talking about Knight A5 here
relying on the typical idea Queen takes
D5 fails Knight takes C3 with Knight
takes C2 on deck
and that would be a way to defend the
b-pawn and the d-pawn but
it doesn't solve all of the problems
white could just go Queen A4 Queen B5
and then the Knight on A5 uh kind of
starts to dangle awkwardly
yeah I know this just looks good for
White and the bishop on F6 uh it's fine
there but it's just not participating in
the way it would like to and the bishop
105 as well it's away from the queen
side where now more of the action is
taking place so in 985 I like your
suggestion honestly Queen B or A4 or
queen B5 mid Queen E5 I like the least
because A6 there's that additional
opportunity for black but sometimes you
want to induce A6 because that makes
some of the dark scores weak but this is
a lovely move the queen is sort of in
amongst the trees and it's very hard to
dislodge from before because remember
this Knight is now tied down to the bee
pond and a move like B6 just doesn't
look very appealing it weakens more
squares this does have the Contours of
one of those like you said grunfeldy
slab type positions where White's having
all of the fun on both sides of the
board also the time situation is not
looking great for Mama jar if he's
almost two minutes down yeah that's not
what you want if you play B6 you want to
say Bishop F5 to B7 for black you need
to cover up those light squares because
every single pawn move when you push
upon you don't no longer control the
squares as previously covered you weaken
those light squares and move like V6 and
while we see a trade and unfortunately
for black you're not ready to play Rook
f8 to C8 that was a blood oh my goodness
Robert I'm so sorry to interrupt you
this was missed and this one a piece in
one move unbelievable
automatically Rook C1 oh gosh that's a
problem is when you don't expect blunder
is from your Super Jam opponent right if
if they were playing me they were like
wait a second Queen B6 that looks wrong
but because it's Mama jar of again oh
it's it's good I'm gonna flip the board
here we usually look from White's
perspective
um but that was insane Robert I mean
that is a kind of movie spot maybe it's
well it's not 3am for ding
it certainly is not that is the first
missed opportunity of the match now the
good news for white is that he's still
very much he's still very much better
here there's no doubt that white is
still in control of the game but it's
funny uh you actually don't want to know
that you missed that because that
feeling of knowing that you could have
won the game in one move really
interferes with your thinking so
ignorance is bliss and chess it really
is you know somebody could tell him
later he'll see it posted at some point
but for now he probably doesn't even
realize he missed Bishop C7 and white
has a lead in The Clock white has the
control of the C file with the queen and
the Rook there though black is pretty
solid right if you don't suffer any sort
of real pressure in the next few moves
black doesn't have any true weakness in
the position
that's absolutely right and A6 here by
Mama Jarvis stop B5
and now what does white even do we
should remind everybody that there's a
back ranked Checkmate theme available
for white because of that pawn on H6 so
a move like 95 you're not taking that 95
because Queen takes Rook back rank is
going to be a problem and thank you for
the Chris Berman I love that right oh
one of my favorites no that that merits
a whoop and that Rook on C8 is yeah it's
problematic and this is sort of a
double-edged sword on the one hand it
x-rays the queen but on the other hand
the queen x-rays The Rook 95 looks
Mighty tempting here
but ding taking a while here maybe he
wants something more subtle like Queen
B3 or queen C5 that would be in ding's
spirit just seems a little bit hesitant
here yeah there's Queen B3 okay so he's
putting crush on that D5 Pawn again but
now the Knight can move if it wants to
and queen back I like to move my shocker
here I think it's just solid he's just
trying to make sure that all of his
bases are covered here and I like Rook
C5 for white just bring that Rook up
attack D5 again maybe play B5 and try to
explode the position I do think that
white has a nagging advantage
he's got an A4
and did he not miss
oh Knight takes D4 there's he takes D4
defending the Rook on seven that's close
but is there some sort of I can smell a
tactic here oh then play G5 maybe and
then G4 because the Knight can't take on
G5 because of why not
E5 oh my gosh I was thinking oh my
goodness for some reason I thought that
it works before but right
but no but E5 actually opens up the
attack on the night wow yeah oh if you
take with the bishop for that see that's
what I was thinking I forgot what Knight
takes G5 if you play G5 and Bishop takes
G5 then you trade and have that Knight
takes D4 tactic that was cool right
because now The Rook on C1 is undefended
and Knight takes E2 track is threatened
but that was missed by Mahmoud and now
Dan continues to pressure the queen side
of D5 we're gonna see most probably a
trade down the C file and you know
what's interesting is that with the
Queens remaining on the board the H6
Pawn is clearly a strength if the Queens
go off the board then you can start
talking about that pawn potentially is a
liability but right now it's fully
anchored by the bishop no problems there
30 seconds now for shock this is looking
probably a little bit better than the
position did about 10 moves ago but the
time situation really worries me here
yeah and I think we're about to see some
pieces being swapped off and if I'm
black I'm just trying to figure out what
do I do with my Bishops and F6 and F5
like is the bishop F5 going to go into
G4 and just trade off for one of the
pieces there I just don't get a sense of
what Black's piece are doing if you give
white a few free moves Knight E5 comes
in there and then even a G4 push that
bishop and F5 you look at the E6 and G6
pawns that Bishop could be trapped on
its very Square
indeed and I think with those
considerations in mind chakra are trying
to plug the C file and he he faces white
with the decision now does dingler and
take that Knight on C4 I'm pretty
attached to this light squared Bishop I
feel like it holds White's position
together but you know who's not attached
that Bishop is Grandmaster dingley Ren
but the evaluation bar was attached was
attached to the bishop yeah I I skip a
second yes keeping it was the better
choice but I do understand why he
captured but now that Bishop on F5 can
sync itself into D3 uh yeah the queen
can come into D5 this is starting to
look very very pleasant for black
yeah I mean I understand oh Bishop takes
C5 that's a pretty bold decision as well
F6 and shocker are just trying to solve
the problems on the king side
as quickly as he can he might throw in
G5 as well but Bishop finally section
off that pawn threatens Bishop E7 all of
a sudden so he he retreated but I
thought Bishop I don't like Bishop g3 at
all I agree
he is waiting for that Queen to be
distracted Queen E7 Queen G7 Checkmate
so maybe he wants to lead with the queen
but Bishop D6 felt a little more uh
pressing agreed than something like B6
yeah that's a nasty move because if the
queen takes them the queen sinks its
teeth into E7 with Checkmate seven
seconds over Chuck I think that
objectively the position is probably
close to equal right now it's the time
situation that worries me the most Rook
A8 camera attacking the queen Classic
Country Queen takes D3 work here like
Queen D3 Pawn takes you take the queen
on D and they'll Rook D1 you win the D3
pontian so it's a pawn oh my goodness
that's cool but then Black Goes Rook D6
and wins the b-pawn at the end so maybe
LNG 5 king G6 comes so maybe instead of
Rook D1 I play a king F1 he does it
right King F1 King E1 and get the pawn
the slow way what about Rook C7 check
first so maybe black should go D2 first
to distract the work he's gonna lose one
time oh no
he made the same reaction we did he was
like what am I doing I need to move oh
my goodness I think the move D2 Robert
would have given excellent drawing
chances for black because that would of
force The Rook to remain on the first
Rank
and the combination of attacking the
b-pawn and the h-spot should have given
black enough for a drop it's hard to
break her here to start for shock to
steal a phrase from our friend James
Canty that's not a move and he needed to
make a move I don't care what it was but
he needed to make a move there he lost
on time and that's what happens in the
early stages here first of all you're
playing a five minute game most of these
players just play three minute blitz so
you're not used to having the extra time
and then it's your first game and you're
not in the blitz warmed up mode and you
just start thinking because the position
is so interesting you want to perfect
your end game and then the next thing
you know you have no time left and game
two here playing a sort of King's Indian
attack style looks very solid approached
by Mama jar but that's not what we've
come to expect from him either he is no
he takes the fight all of his opponents
but you know Robert allow me to be a
backseat Andy here for a second and you
know I asked for forgiveness it's 4am
I'm grumpy but you know I feel like that
shouldn't happen I think this I I see in
these SEC matches some of these games uh
players lose on time but somebody like
shock I mean he has to have an eye on
the clock at all times and the the the
instinct to make you know that some move
is better than no move should be so
firmly ingrained that unless you have a
Wi-Fi issue you know this kind of thing
uh shouldn't happen at all and I agree
with you I think he's going to make the
necessary adjustments and I don't think
it's going to happen again in this match
but that that's really deflating you
know when you defend so well and you
lose on time you know I'm always the one
shutting down your puns but forgive me
it's just that for 7 A.M it's early for
me so don't you complain about the time
no where's the shot clock I mean come on
man where's your pond game like that
that was just waiting to be set and so
yeah he was just just Dilly Dalling
there he loses time he looks actually
upset like we have him on camera here he
doesn't look like he's very happy at the
moment and I don't know if it's about
his current position or he's still
reflecting on the last game but in this
game Dania so there's the double fiend
Kettle for black black has control of
the D5 square and white has current
control over the E5 Square so that's the
one thing is black can't punch through
the move e75 no and he chooses to bring
his Knight in first but you see the eval
bar take a little bit of a hit there I
just feel like black is incredibly solid
as long as you don't miss C3 to C4 with
the bishop loose on B7 that's why you're
playing Queen C7 both protecting B7 and
attacking E5 yeah this is just looking
extremely good for black so solid this
is a ding type of position and here's
what I'll say in such situations uh from
personal experience uh it's actually an
annoying thing from White's perspective
that black doesn't have the pawn on E5
because when the pawn is on E5 it's a
Target as it stands black can play E6 at
the right moment and safeguard that
night on D5
White's position is relatively solid it
looks active but there are no targets
the pawn on D3 is a pretty serious
long-term weakness and white is
constantly having to reckon with this
idea of moving the Knight away from D5
and offering a rather undesirable trade
of light squared bishops from White's
point of view so black is slightly
better here no doubt about it but shock
is very very good at finagling some sort
of an initiative out of these types of
positions and one of the key points is
that D3 Pawn is a bit loose that pawn on
C3 takes away the D4 and B4 squares but
it kind of wishes it could push back to
C2 because when you play that Knight F6
move I really liked your suggestion then
now the bishops get traded the king side
is a little loose for white those light
squares the D3 Pawn is going to be Atari
with a worse can double but he goes A5
sometimes we feel we can have to
activate our Rooks or breathe in the
center let's activate that Rook by
pushing our pawn and trying to trade on
V6
yeah sort of as my coach would say
lengthening the diagonal or the file for
The Rook
and he does push A6 so in the first game
ding pushes his Pawn to H6 and the
second Chuck which respond to A6 and
there comes the other Corner Pawn this
is what I would call the alpha Zero
Effect I think it's taken the chest
World by storm players of all ratings
are just fully obsessed now with the
idea of pushing the corner pawns as soon
as possible and I'm not complaining
that's my style too well part of the
reason I love it as well is that they're
not doing this for checkmate right the
oppon went to H6 not for checkmate the
Palm went to A6 here not for checking it
out that they're throwing their pawns
forward to gain space and the bishop 108
is tucked away it's protected it's on
any danger whatsoever but that's gain of
space could be really useful say the
queen is just disappear from the board
then what has moved Rook A5 to attack
Black's pawns now in Queen of C7 is
going to stay put and I think the move
B5 to B4 should be played for black
because when your opponent goes for some
kind of King side strike you often
attack towards the center and if B4 is
met by C4 well then look at that D4
Square there that Knight would like to
reroute its way over to D4 at some point
and the D3 Pawn is stuck in place it's a
backwards bomb
it is indeed and after B4 perhaps what I
should consider Bishop D2 uh trying to
to preserve uh this sort of bumper-like
structure uh as flimsy as it is uh it
does allow white to keep these Central
squares under control but ding now
taking a very very long think uh what
else might he be contemplating maybe
he's considering H5 although I kind of
doubt it I wouldn't weaken the G5 I
wouldn't be too afraid of light playing
H5 because it could simply be met with
G5 perhaps he wants to move the Knight
away to F6 maybe he thinks this is the
appropriate time to do that you could
also trade everything on E5
also doesn't seem too appetizing because
as you mentioned Robert Rook A5 it's
gonna be pretty strong in any end game
and there comes B4 yeah maybe there is
some specifics with B4 because uh they
give away the C4 Square it is a
committal choice but part of the reason
I like it is even after Bishop D2 black
can trade on C3 and then bring that Rook
from d8 to B8 that'll be a newly opened
file The f8 Rook is not participating so
that Rook can then go to d8 as well and
then you can see how to proceed from
there I just feel like black suddenly
the position's opening up not that
really that dingler has a better
position it just becomes more enjoyable
to play because of the newly found
activity in an important detail on top
of that in the event of Rook V8 white
has the sacrifice on G6 it looks very
strong looks like you're recovering the
night but black as the Saving Grace
Queen F7 uh indirectly defending that
Knight through the X-ray so that's all
good for black but ding deciding to keep
the tension on the queen side and he
does play H5 which again comes as quite
the surprise to me because it does yield
this G5 Square now Bishop G5 is probably
not it's not probably not the time for
it but
uh but that's something to contemplate a
little bit later I I wonder if this is
one of those beautiful subtleties of
this super GM level he committed the
bishop to D2 so he said now I can give
the G5 square if you're thinking about
from dingley Ren's perspective because
you just spent a turn on Bishop B2
you're not gonna waste another by moving
to G5 especially because now The Rook
can go to B8 and has a good place there
so I wonder if that's what he's thinking
maybe there's an exchange sacrifice in
the works Bishop G5 B takes C3 also
needs to be looked at so it's an
interesting Dynamic at this point and
shock react just doesn't seem that
comfortable and maybe I'm reading too
much into his facial expressions and his
gesticulations but it just seems like
he's not found his footing in this match
yet no I don't think you are and I think
he hasn't and the aforementioned idea of
that night heading to default this is
exactly the kind of position that Ding
is known for it's not boring it's not
dry but it's just positional enough the
plans are clearly defined and white just
doesn't have
that much going on and you know the
e-ball bar is so deceptive in these
cases because you know yes you have to
consider the objective evaluation but
you also have to consider how easy the
plans are for both sides in this case I
think uh only black is is having the fun
in terms of all in terms of the plans
shocker has activated his miners where
does he go from here Queen to E4 he
centralizes his Queen I like what he's
doing all this makes sense to me and the
queen could find itself on B7 and if
that Queen gets there you have to watch
out from Black's perspective is the A7
pawn part of the good thing about the
pumping on A6 that's close to promotion
so if you're not careful there could be
problems over there on the queen side
but the clearly defined Pawn structure
is better for black look at that D3 Pawn
look the D4 squares you're highlighting
so it's white is relying on activity
black is saying I have a better
structure to work with and especially
than Knight and F5 it's against a dark
Square Bishop you can't touch that
Knight on F5 and then E5 can't really
move for white because the bishop on G7
will slice through the position so it
just the A7 Pawn is really what white is
relying on for the counter play
necessary to sort of maintain chances in
this game
yeah I think that's a very accurate
assessment as both players are now at
approximately one minute Rook to E4 this
takes the sting out of the move Knight
C2
and there's a weird kind of idea of
going Knight D7 with an even a weirder
Fork against the rook and the pawn on C5
chakra has done a pretty darn good job
of whipping up I don't know if counter
plays the right word but he's definitely
made this position more double-edged and
ding is now well under a minute this is
a pretty important position uh to to
play accurately but I don't know exactly
what black should do here he played
makes a very bold decision takes that
night off the board but gives up that
very prized dark scored Bishop yeah okay
because if if the bishop took there was
Knight F3 check to then take that bishop
and then D3 would fall but I like that
takes E5 a lot because even if D3 Falls
A7 still a weakness Bishop H6 you know
can be played in the near future so
you're maintaining all the benefits as
you said like a kind of a decision you
wouldn't expect with Bishop takes E5 but
white is trying to then pounce and queen
B6 you're giving a pass Pawn but also
claiming my work's on A8 it's not doing
anything besides the defensive means
right now let's open up the a file and
then I'm going to win your A6 font
that's exactly right in the event of a
trade and shucker is not going to trade
because black can actually double on
that a file the a pawn is now a Sitting
Duck Chuck are playing King G2 and ding
dropping his Knight back to C6 and was
that a blunder
why was it a blunder because after Rook
G5 I guess black is kind of stuck in the
last year C7 Queen trade and this time
chakra is not gonna miss Bishop C7
didn't miss that move in the last game
Shakira is not going to miss it in this
game that is a devastating threat in
five seconds here for ding Rook FCA he
has to stop it no no those Rook G6
Bishop H6 that's almost a queen trade
but it doesn't work because there's
Queen C7 at the end but is there just
yeah Bishop D6 hitting the pawn maybe
that was the wrong angle there Robert I
think Bishop E3 would have been the more
accurate way of doing that what's going
on here we've got tactics I think with
one second Queen C6 accurate move though
yep and he's still in the game that real
country five is kind of stranded can can
you get a king G7 F6 in or trap The Rook
there no The Rook now has full swing on
the fifth rank Rook C7 though and white
should be winning this bishop takes A7
incredible turnaround oh and that's a
mouse slip
yeah trying to drag the work all the way
down to D3 that one got stuck on D7 it's
like the old little uh joke about the
Russian player Vladimir simagan uh very
tactical player yeah he he was a GM and
he played a game in the 40s E4 C6 he was
black D4 D6 after the game his friend
comes up Vladimir uh E4 C6 D4 D6 I
didn't have the strength to push the
pawn all the way to D5 that was the
answer I love that story it's so good
yeah uh well
I think even though the match is now
even Mama jar won that game I do kind of
feel like that still wasn't his style of
game it became it later but yeah
something fell off out of the opening so
I hope for Mom and Jar's sake that now
he can you know relax a bit he did lose
game one now he's back it's an even
score just play chess both of these
players are so strong and they don't
fear one another they respect each other
and look at this this is like the
ultimate ding start to a game right it's
like and crazy solid uh you're trying to
induce a weakness here or there if you
play B5 and the C6 Pawn is backwards
white might have A4 if you play a move
you know sometimes you see like a rook
A7 which is not in this position The
Rook is misplaced maybe take a good
place later what what a bishop F6 and
queen B6 takes takes Queen B6 slide it
in
that looks amazing black has to play GF
and ding immediately bounces and soccer
are missed it now GF is not the end of
the world Robert but it's pretty pretty
darn close to the end of the world you
do not want to weaken your structure
like this this early in the game no that
looks terrible especially because you
have the F5 Square under your control
too like
what oftentimes happens exactly you're
highlighting their Knight H4 to F5 you
just keep pushing forward and Bishop to
five two oh no this is E4 this is
atrocious black can't Castle the King
has nowhere to go it can't Castle long
because you've already moved the Rook
well I kind of feel like you know I know
you're the prophet but I I was about
you're just saying like well you can't
please move okay seven even though
sometimes an idea and this is it clearly
backfiring where uh black wasn't fully
developed wasn't ready and H5 that's not
really an attack I feel like it's a
defensive move because the Palm was
threatened and this is what you do kings
in the center open it up Donna this is
probably the worst opening we'll see or
like the worst position right out of the
opening we'll see in this match very
likely and uh probably at the very least
until the bullet uh but you know this is
another thing you can see here is that
Ding is not he's not a passive player I
think people when they think of
positional players they think oh you
know he's never going to go for anything
tactical that's absolutely untrue ding
does not hesitate to open up the
position when he needs to and that is
the Hallmark of the modern Universal
Super GM you know you could have your
Tendencies You could have your
preferences but when push comes to shove
all of these players are going to do
what the position requires of them
whether that's positional or tactical
and I think ding is a great example of
that and here we see an ih4 seamlessly
weaving a tactical move like E4 but
still not forgetting about the idea of
eventually getting a knight or a bishop
to F5
I just don't even know what moves
suggests for black because there's an
open G file for your Rook but as soon as
you move that Rook to G8 I'm looking to
H5 pawn and the H6 square that Rook
probably needs to stay defensive over
here and not just go for any sort of
Wishful attack so
you don't want to take on e4 that's
clear to me then the Knight will just
take back and wise pieces are hopping
into the game
oh and then I guess Knight g395 yeah
F5 by chakra are clearly an attempt to
to change the course of the game which
which I like
what about
is there e takes D5 Queen takes H4 G3
maybe that's too creative maybe not I
like that actually that looks really
good
or what about even E5 in this position
E5 probably also is good because the
bishop on E6 it's a big Pawn but I think
sometimes the problem with playing E5 is
if Queen takes H4 he takes D6 if you
don't win some of the material like that
Bishop is protecting the house so uh
it's one of this decision I would open
the board up he takes D5 like you first
suggested allow Queen H4 and play G3 uh
but I could see the downside in that too
obstacle Bishops not exactly what you
want maybe not a clear way how to uh may
win a pawn or something like that so you
can just win upon F5 directly if you
want it I think e65 is probably more in
things style but
um
so far he's clearly not shied away from
complications I I personally would not
be able to resist the temptation to go
E5 but yeah he does take on D5
and the reason that I was not as keen on
this is because after well first let's
see what trucker does
I feel like uh Bishop takes H2 was a
move there okay G3
that I did not expect I thought he would
have to go Queen F6 Robert well this
looks like it has to be completely
losing look at the evaluation bar it's
going Sky High here it's I mean T1 if
even Bishop takes F5 yeah just grab it
takes takes and I guess soccer air was
relying on this idea but it doesn't even
create a threat and white can just go E7
E7 Rook D1 Rook d8 checkmates
ouch yeah I mean the King has plenty of
breathing room here F2 is not hanging
this is totally one-sided and ding has
plenty of time
uh to figure out the most precise path
to Victory
chakra has completely collapsed here
this kind of playing like aggressive as
a form of Defense can work especially in
bullet chess but right now with all this
time on the clock I we know dingler and
missed that Bishop C7 attacks in game
one so he was not as alert as he should
have been in that first game but in this
position no come on Bishop takes G3
he'll just push that pawn move the rook
in there's no attack for black in fact
it's Black's king that's getting made in
Dania look at that Rook on A7 has it
moved since it defended the B7 we're on
the same switch it's a source of all of
Black's problems I think our eyes are
inexorably drawn to the Rook on A7 and
that mb6 it's never good when you've got
you know pieces just kind of buried and
stuck in molasses on one side of the
board and all of the action occurs on
the other side that's just never good
you can't have you know how you might be
tracker for Magnus Carlson but uh all of
your pieces have to be working members
of society otherwise you're going to get
crushed and that's exactly what happened
in this game E7 check is going to happen
and then Rook 81 is going to win the
game yeah because your King has to go to
eat otherwise E8 equals Queen will go a
full Rook ahead for white so
yeah Bishop H2 and King Jutsu
not even not even a single check
well there's Queen G7 but then King can
come in that's F3
why not you're a bully I wasn't saying
there's Rook G8 check as well but then
you can go King H1 so you could uh you
cannot take on H2
that's a wonderful sequence though
because you think that after King at
your queen H4 check would be the
response but in fact Queen F4 check
that's really cool and it's made yeah
this is a typical uh blind spot for a
lot of players they only consider kind
of the latter sequence But first you
give the check you toss the King off of
H2 and now after Queen H4 the H3 square
is no longer covered so there's no need
for any of that he goes King F1 and
rookie two which is an alternate way of
uh preventing all of the checks and one
nice line here is 95 1965 Queen takes E2
Knight F6 mate there are a gazillion
mates this is completely resignable I
mean Rook A8 I guess possibly oh my God
rookie Aid maybe Knight E4 yes
absolutely now that is a little bit more
elegant same kind of concept
no this is Bishop C7 is also maybe
possible
try to go to kh1 some ideas I'm still
thinking about that sequencing we're
stopping the queen of four check and I
think that's the hardest thing is
stopping short those are the easiest
oversights to making chess because we
always assume that the pieces are going
to move the furthest off the board and
create the most threats but just
stopping short is a a big thing and I
mean this is a demolition dingly Wren
should be really happy and he seems so
focused because he yeah I'm looking at
this position like you don't need to
focus on this one buddy you won this
game right no you know things are under
control and you know his hands are not
on the keyboard so he knows that he's
gonna have plenty of time to kind of in
a leisurely way bring his hands back on
the mouse it was Queen D2 Queen D7 and
queen d8 oh come on
95. now now just trade everything on D5
but Knight D5 Pawn takes Queen takes and
you're you're gonna checkmate with
Bishop D7 Checkmate yeah that's coming
and if you go black goes F6 and the
bishop is Gonna Come to G6
gosh everything is made here
pretty what a complete as you said
Demolition and ding looked really good
in that game obviously things looked
very Grim for shock after he allowed
Bishop takes F6
but nonetheless the the technique there
was I mean left absolutely
left nothing to be desired that was
perfect I was gonna say though the one
good thing about losing in that fashion
is from Mom and jara's perspective is
you're like okay I won't allow this
bishop pics f600 that was just a simple
blunder and after that I had no chance
that's what the mentality that you have
so that helps you get over losses like
that more quickly it was a one move
blunder I can play better versus just
getting thoroughly outplayed or like
that person's just better than I am
right now uh oh these lines are so sharp
oh yeah they are I play this with white
um and I've lost a lot of games
precisely I've struggled to to meet this
B5 sacrifice which has become very very
topical yeah and I I always feel like
these structures are somehow a lot
looser for white than they are for black
because the white King on E1 just
doesn't seem to have a good home
as is evidenced by chakra's last move
this is generally where the king Parks
itself that pawn and F3 you know it's
like the way vampires are buried with
spikes right that pawn is preventing and
you like to point this out Roberts
preventing that F6 knight from
delivering an ass to check still 95 93 I
feel like Black's position is just a
tiny bit more fun to play and blacks up
a pawn to boot so if white isn't quick
with whatever it is that you're going
for you're just down material and oh
gosh if that happens it's over so G5
don't capture that pawn not all pawns
that look free are free
um so maybe Knight G3 trying to get that
C4 Pawn get a rook to E1 because the
Queen and King are on the same line
right Knight B6 doesn't really protect
the pawn
he's on the same page
and after 95 yeah like you said Bishop
D2 kind of try to Castle by hand and
ultimately if White gonna can achieve
all of that then yes uh black might
start paying the price for uh you know
for this G5 move which creates obviously
very significant weaknesses on the king
side
but seeing the yeah Knight E5 just looks
great that score is carved out for that
night that's the benefit of having this
Pawn on G5 it's bad in a sense because
your king feels a little weaker but it's
great when you take away the F4 Square
from an opponent and white at some point
may need to strike by like an h2h4 move
to blast that side open but White's King
isn't exactly safe sitting on F2
no and there's constant tactics with
Knight G4 and Knight D3 and knights all
over the place now what exactly has been
contemplating he might be considering
the possibility of trading on C3 I don't
really see the hurry to be honest
but there's a reason that he's playing
and I'm not but I don't like Bishop C3
and the reason why is after we trade and
then you protect C4 with 95 I can take
on C4 because after Knight takes C4 oh
great eye so you're opening up the
fourth rank whereas the bishop on B4
would prevent this tactic so I don't
like Bishop takes C3 I think it's too
committal and it gives white additional
options that you don't want to see how
do you see that at 7 39 a.m I guess
maybe in three hours I'll I'll start to
see stuff like that you know because I
was thinking about random tactics and
then somehow sometimes they're relevant
and here the queen a4check plays his
part and you want the honest truth Dania
is I I initially said Knight B6 you can
still take on C4 but you can't because
the FM Knight takes D4 rookie one you're
trying to win the queen right on the
file but the Knight comes back to E5 oh
nice it started with a it started with a
blunder and then it went to a uh a good
idea well as Abraham Lincoln said all
great things start with a blunder
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
oh well I I do
I mean he won night before
okay but Bishop B2 I guess
is reasonable
there's also I mean queen C2 Knight F5
but the D5 Paul might be lost I'm going
like for positional means in a tactical
position so I I I don't know if Queen C2
is uh too slow yeah but I just
recognized that the issue with Bishop B2
might also just be that black in this
position takes on C3 and then takes on
D5 although I wouldn't be too scared
with white White's not really you know
white doesn't care about Pawns in this
position white cares really only about
uh the possibility of completing his
development Knight C to E4 sorry
completion development can you tell me
that one again well I was just saying
that
wait am I supposed to no I was joking
because he moved a piece that he'd
already moved right oh 1944 yeah exactly
he he waited for me to say that and then
he plays Knight C4
um
train on trading on C3 has now passed
that Bishop before has kind of been left
in the dust and uh you see this
technique sometimes where you develop a
piece which stares at another piece then
that other piece vacates the premises
that Bishop is just kind of you know
it's been left to stag at the prom yeah
no unlike G nothing wrong with going to
the problem but I was gonna make a you
know GF comment so a joke there right
but oh my god oh anyway I'm supposed to
do that Robert yeah have you forgotten
what the roles are uh no but I am trying
to figure out how to improve this
position for white because it does look
really good and that so A3 played Bishop
A5
I almost want to play the move B4 here
does it work
oh my goodness B4 here yes
and what if I add Basalt Bishop B2 oh
Bishop B5 and Bishop B2 yeah
oh that's sick and he's played it
it feels honestly I don't think there's
a player that I'm happier that I guess
their move correctly than chakra because
he is so explosive and I just love his
tactical style and I've actually played
him in a blitz tournament like 10 years
ago and he wiped me off the board so
just to be able to predict his move
every now and then that feels good
no that was awesome and I honestly
completely forgot that this diagonal
even existed that Knight on F6 another
problem with with the move G5 is that it
has left this Square undefended
now chakra are taking his time here he's
not rushing to recapture on V4 I see
thinking about Queen D4 possibly I would
just take on B4 played Bishop B2 but
then there's the move C3 for black which
saves the day so I'm gonna acknowledge
that I really think about the
consequences too deeply here but look at
this line that's what could happen it's
made literally mate that is not good
so it's probably what he's considering
right now though is just what happens
after C3 it takes the bishop rather than
Knight and now pieces are getting traded
it's not like Black's King is truly safe
although black is up a palm
yeah and I I also threw the move Queen
D4 out the window because after Knight
BJ C5 there's this devastating threat of
going Bishop B6 so
could I mean is there any alternative to
atix before because if not then you
should probably move first and think
later is there something like Bishop E3
or D4 if you really really really wants
to get his Bishop on that diagonal but
then there's still Knight takes D5
Bishop B6
right ideas so probably not Bishop on A5
is surprisingly resilient it keeps
dropping back to V6 or C5 okay so he
bites the bullet he takes and takes on
C4 oh that looks suspicious
yeah it feels like we were talking about
how white one would be quick with the
development and now White's not really
fully developed and the bishop on C4 is
hangs a black and even Castle I imagine
and right
yeah just castle and then F5 and Bishop
C5 is going to be a pretty big threat
for example Castle's Bishop B2 and black
doesn't even have to take on C4 if he
doesn't want to he can play off five
yeah and ding plays F5 immediately which
possibly is even stronger well it does
allow that Bishop B5 check so that
that's an additional opportunity that
white would not have had had he castles
for so I actually think that was a good
idea but wrongly executed he should have
castled because there would be no Bishop
check which gets the bishop out of Dodge
and now maybe you can play Queen D4 and
he does and all of a sudden it's a fork
and he can finally eliminate that Bishop
from before Oh a funny line is after
Queen takes before E3 is possible if
Bishop takes you through this queen
takes you through but the king can
simply hide away on E2 yeah that's an
umbrella Pawn right and shields the
white king yeah and for that reason no
but ding has completely lost control of
the game now The Rook can come to E1 and
white can finally complete uh that kind
of castling by hand that was started you
know a million moves ago he goes Bishop
B2 first
this is looking
might be suspicious for blackworks E8
threatening Rook C2
ships these things oh yeah that's true I
was like wondering if you could throw in
the E3 check but the king would still
sit on uh E2 and uh taking on D5 is
always going to be a problem okay Bishop
on C3
there's ideas of stacking The Rook on C6
and weakening white slight squares now
the question is does the king hide away
on G3 that's not out of the question it
goes E2 so if the king were not in F7
Rook C6 Knight D5 could be just
devastating because the knight's coming
to F4 and exactly is in trouble but the
king being on F7 is just in the wrong
place I would still contemplate this
because if you go Queen C4 I drop the
bishop to E6 and the moment that Knight
comes to F4
I'll tell you what with a minute on the
clock that's not easy to play ding
taking essentially all of his time I
think he's calculating that but he might
end up just going Rook a to B8 I don't
see exactly what's wrong with that
either maybe it's too slow 97 97 was not
on my radar not on mine either now one
of the ideas is that now taking is
impossible with a rook C2 and queen B7
which looks like the most natural reply
to me is met by like Bishop D3 check or
something so like there's or even RP is
simple yeah I'm going for like the
complex tactics and New Year's winnipes
so uh
what does white do here you don't want
to take on D7 I don't think so
certainly not
because maybe just rookie one
but
nah there would be eight and the Knights
coming into e or C5
well now Knight C5 is still very much
possible or you could throw in Rook a V8
first and see where the queen goes yeah
95.
seven seconds though for dang he's gotta
move and the problem for the white king
is like you don't really know are you
getting checkmated is Bishop D3 check
gonna be good can I take the E3 pawns
and opening up more files it's a
struggle but ding is down on time he's
down on time but what a crazy position
now Knight takes C6 F4 weight allowing
Bishop G4 check then King takes E3 in
two seconds for ding he's gotta make a
move oh my gosh taken on that foreign
I love it I love it that's just that's
it Bishop D3 oh gosh Bishop D3 yep and
wait a second this is still not over
this is still not over Queen A7 but now
the hunt has begun
a lot of checks again he's not gonna
move no he got he flagged
oh my God he flagged
I'm speechless that never happens to me
but also this is the second time this
match a player is flagged what is
happening on this queen F7 I don't know
I mean Knight 66 gets mated but at least
get Madden I think they're trying to
make me feel better because I always
freeze and flag and both of them have
done that right now so what do you make
they're taking their halftime break
right we're Midway through the five plus
one segment here like what do you make
of what we've seen thus far I know
dingley Wren has the lead but right
who's the favorite right now I'm
confused
it's been a weird start to the match
Robert because you know you've had this
sort of weird ending to two of these
games uh with Joker are flagging once
and ding flagging once I feel like ding
has been in control of most of these
games I just get the sense that he's
he's dictated matters he's found a lot
of great ideas but well it hasn't
translated to to the match score so I
mean I think whether you know his
ability to keep it's it's great to
dictate the terms of the match it's like
possession time in soccer Robert you can
have you know 80 of The Possession but
if you're not scoring goals I think
that's not good for anything so we're
gonna see if ding can actually make that
translate in the second half of this
five minute portion well we'll have to
see in a few minutes we'll take a quick
break but when return more from the
speed Chess Championship
foreign
[Music]
once you've played a lot with Magnus you
understand that he never coasts so if
you make a sliding accuracy sometimes I
can still Bowl into turning a game that
feels like it's about to be a draw into
a game that that you might lose if he's
the player who's overall the strongest
the most accurate and the most
consistent he also puts pressure on you
in a way that some players sometimes let
up on the pressure while Magnus usually
doesn't ever let off
and we are back Donya it's been a
whirlwind of a first few games here but
this match is important some of the top
players in the world I'm pretty excited
for the World Chess Championship we just
heard five minute carwana's thoughts
it's going to be Magnus it's going to be
yawned upon the she it's starting in
just a few weeks now
it's crazy I mean these things just
approach and um you know you've got
speed Chess Championship all the way up
until the world championship and you've
got the two together it's an incredible
month of Chess just November December
they're gonna go down in history as some
of the most epic months of Chess history
I mean wow
all you can eat buffet
it really is and we don't even have to
go to Vegas for it but for some reason I
thought it was three to two in I thought
so too
is it like are we misremembering yeah we
are I guess it's two to two well I'm
that is not necessarily yeah it's gonna
be our excuse the whole show it is two
to two we are just wrong I in my head it
was thinking the room was up three to
two now and that's just wrong so okay
we're into this next game here uh it's a
pawn sacrifice to this point but Mama
jar didn't he use this to no I think he
put something similar to beat Kasparov
in the uh rapid and Blitz when Gary
played but these kind of things can be
very very dangerous if you know what
you're doing from the black side oh
extremely I mean these Queens gambitics
I mean there's Knight takes F7 here and
Bishop F7 Queen H5 you see this kind of
tactic in a lot of different openings
white recovers the bishop and at first
blush it looks like White's you know
crazy better King on F7 is really weak
but the reality is that black is okay
here because the king can tuck itself on
GA and black doesn't have a passer on D4
and black has a slight lead in
development so the reality uh is quite a
bit more complex I still like White's
position I think the dark skirts Robert
are quite concerningly weak for black
and in a Blitz game this could be hard
to handle but we see a transition into
an end game I don't know probably closer
to equal than anything oh yeah I like
that transition for black for sure
because when you try to evaluate should
I trade Queens You Look whose King is
safer White's King is very safe Black's
King a bit out in the open so I would
not have won the trade Queens if I were
doing the Ren and Bishop E6 black is
complete development in fact the King on
F7 could be useful in the end game and
the D4 pawn it may be doubled it's on a
dark square but good luck getting to it
it'll take much of your time and many of
your resources
that's right and white kind of has to
decide what his plan is going to be F4
is is pretty tempting what do you think
black's going to do against that for
yeah four looks pretty good I'm not sure
at some point Rook C8 Knight B4 type of
ideas or probably what Black's gonna go
for but if you don't play F4 black will
play D5 so you might kind of be forced
to play F4 if you're trying to seek any
sort of edge here
you might be f-forced to play F4 oh my
gosh is that what you're saying oh gosh
Donya
my first of the day we're gonna be here
all week aren't we it's gonna be the two
of us non-stop let me listen to your
puns all right I'm gonna have to get
used to it I'm gonna get back into it
yeah for sure uh Rook D1 so what about
D5 is there something wrong with that
move no I think there isn't and Mama
drift plays it I think that maybe white
wants to just play F3
and then perhaps somehow get the bishop
to F2 and ultimately claim that pawn is
more of a weakness than the strength but
obviously I'm pretty doubtful that this
gives any serious Advantage maybe just
Rook ac1
yeah the bishop on G5 is extremely
annoying to deal with though because you
can't kick it out and that means you
can't put a rook on d8 so that's why
he's going for this exchange he's giving
up his e-pawn wins the d-pawn there is
no challenge along the D file but the
bishop on E6 also covers that very
important D7 squared dinos so I don't
know where White's planning to break
through from but what of course has the
better position
yeah but I think the combination of
obviously colored Bishops and as you
said The Bishop's control of the D7
Square
should give black enough uh to secure
the draw here H5
stopping G4 and then the white king can
go King H2 King G3 F4 and they may play
G4 like that's the movie you really want
to make happen and the dark squares are
yours for the taking
yeah I have to say the more I look at
this the more that plan seems incredibly
nasty because if white can win the
e-pawn then you know opposite colored
Bishops are not when you have an extra
pawn and it's a Blitz game you're going
to have serious winning chances that's
right and there's also a threats against
the black king you may say well there
are no queens in the board you're not
gonna Checkmate but if that first Rook
say goes to A4 B4 and then you can tie
down the black on D6 like things could
get out of hand if you're not actually
Rook A4 A6 Rook D6 what do you do as
black after that
yeah that's an incredible kind of case
of domination because if you go Rook E6
you allow rook t7 and I think the ding
is going for that line okay 4a6 played
Rook B4 instead hitting opponent B7 I
think he wants to promote B5 and then
play Rook D6 I like that even more
that's just a smart move to uh include
because uh Rook C7 I don't think works
as a bishop F4 and but then Rook E7
oh and I don't have Bishop D6 at the end
I thought I had Bishop B6 I do not and
then with D7 yeah so I think like
actually should go roxy7 because B5
creates massive weaknesses on the queen
side
although putting doubling your Rooks
behind your isolated Pawn that kind of
pushed is not really ideal right I think
ding is going for the bind here and that
makes a lot of sense to me just saying I
I can then move my piece of the next
truck up to D4 then to B4 you have the
elevator Rooks right they're just moving
right down and trampolining from one
side of the board to the other and you
know these top jams are so patient in
these positions I mean it's in order to
squeeze out a win nothing happens
quickly you know first you have to
accumulate then you have to create the
bind as you said and it's not about some
sort of immediate breakthrough or some
crazy tactic you have to keep inducing
weaknesses keep massaging the advantage
and eventually an opportunity uh to
further expand the advantage is going to
arise
and you know look at this like right
do here Rook E6 Rook D7 check it's not
about winning the B Pawn there was that
pawn B7 which would have been one
earlier it's about getting after that
black king forcing it to the back Rank
and then continuing to press four and I
mean look at this position it's just to
my eyes it has to be an overwhelming
Advantage but then I look at the Evolve
bar and says slightly better another day
at the office yeah this is sort of a
chef's kiss kind of position but
concretely Rook C7 might actually force
a trade of Brooks there was something
funny that I don't think you realize you
just did we said a chef's house I know
yeah I did realize it oh who do you
think I am well you think I'm not alert
or anything it would have been even
better if you didn't realize that you
were making uh so yeah that's just Next
Level yeah you know you just just goes
right in there so this is a good defense
by Mama Joe because now that he has his
Rooks doubled and on an open file rather
than behind his I said Pawn he could
play this move Rook C7 his King can get
back out to F7 after dhek for example uh
I would probably go for that like Rook
d8 check Rook A7 to A8 and then hope
that I can try Checkmate this King I'm
just not sure I'm I see any way to do so
and he goes precisely for that line
I was contemplating Rook C8 and he plays
it he's insisting on a trademark C7
I think white might have to trade one
way or another and he finds a good
version of it because now the bishop has
to drop back to C8 I would imagine
uh the bad news though is that the Rook
is for black is coming down to C2 and
yes the Rook is tied to the bishop for
now but it feels like black is gonna be
able to drum up enough counter play to
keep the position not level because
white is better but keeping the balance
and the hilarious thing is that the
bishop on C8 is actually not such a dumb
Bishop it's defending A6 which is
freeing up that Rook to go to C2 exactly
so it may very well have been the case
that Ding you know kind of over thought
it and should have traded Rooks in a
different version he goes back to A7
King suddenly acquiring no small measure
of activity
no but the thing about this is a timely
Rook G7 could be quite annoying for
black to do it but that King can go up
to D5 or F5 because the Rook on C6 is
perfectly placed so uh yes black has an
isolated Pawn what that's hard to Target
you have a dark star Bishop there's a
pawns and a light Square so I I think
with having both pairs of Rooks on the
board White had serious chances now that
the pair of Rooks just got traded that's
a draw for exactly it's going to be a
draw so he's forcing it and that's a you
know on the scoreboard this doesn't mean
very much I mean it's just a draw the
match is still tied but from a
psychological standpoint uh pretty big
result from ahmediara because this is
the kind of position that Ding is really
known for for pressing and Mama Dr have
defended very precisely and basically
Drew from a position of strength so that
almost certainly gave him a measure of
confidence let's see whether that
translates into a win with a white
pieces as we see a very unorthodox
opening I've actually seen this this
Knight C3 and D4 kind of a Vienna Center
game combo I mean what isn't an opening
now
uh everything that I play would be the
answer to your part
that's funny
well I mean this was weird because we
tell
uh students not to move their Queen in
the opening and not only did that queen
move once and then move the second time
so you did right two faux pas you first
moved your queen and then you were the
same piece twice and that is not
recommended usually however why can
Castle Queen side you have a pawn
structure that is no longer uh
symmetrical what
okay what gonna say it doesn't matter
any movies we know it's been out the
window thrown out the window you moved
Queen back to D2 just so he could defend
F2 and he was Queen D3 in the first
place just so he could develop his dark
Square Bishop to eventually Castle Queen
side but it I don't think it was worth
all that time so I'm not going to
justify this opening anymore even if
white objectively is okay
I think Yasser is is probably lying in
bed watching this match it's just
cringing yeah shock we are I respected
greatly as a player but in my day if if
you play chess like this you'd be thrown
out of the tournament
immediately I mean you just don't play
like this in Anatoly car Puffs presents
what's especially funny about that is
you couldn't name players with like more
different styles like they like Mama
jarov and Yasser and then Yasser played
chakra in the world team championship
yeah when he beat him and he beat him we
also now were teammates and it was uh
the opening which you know for most
years without the board I guess we could
just quickly show that opening was it D4
C5 D5 so I just wanted to if we can just
to show the opening it doesn't let me
change the first move of the game
oh well then we'll show it another point
I guess but right I guess when D4 when
D4 is played by either of them we'll be
able to show it
but I remember watching that game live
that must have been a magical experience
like sitting next to the SRC
you know already in semi-retirement just
casually destroys shock your iron he
beat somebody else in that tournament
too right he beat Judah Polgar so
um yeah that
that game was really something it was
just a questionable opening but this is
a questionable opening and what is
happening why does Mom beer keep getting
double isolated Bishops yeah well the
reason the specific I know you're asking
it rhetorically here
Queen takes E3 was not entirely out of
the question but I guess he concluded
that white does not have enough for
potentially a full rook in this line
and he plays vc3 which is never a good
sign now white is not losing here I mean
White's got the two Bishops white
threatens to play H3 how exactly does
black stabilize everything to see go
Queen F6 to see Castle
ding has to make an accurate decision
here I think black should Castle Queen
side I mean like can I just move my
queen out and that what now white wants
because why is Castle Queen started to
attack on the king side but if I Castle
the queen side good luck with your
attack you're attacking nothing right
exactly what exactly are you going to be
using uh in service of the attack but I
feel like castling kingside maybe
accelerates uh the possibility of a
queen side attack for black I think both
is true you can make a case for castling
to either side and probably ding is
thinking about precisely that
oh then it depends also what his current
move is because
um he came by Queen F6 which I really
like he can just Castle as you mentioned
uh that does like at least in the back
of my mind would be mamajarov loves to
be aggressive and attack and castling
King side well Lambda but these two
players have squared off so many times
that dingler ends not just going to be
scared of the reputation of Mama jar of
the way right I might he's just gonna be
like you know what I'm gonna calculate
and right now castling is totally fine
in fact it's good and as you said you
can then accelerate on the queen side
for black and start the attack
but he goes for the Robert Hess approach
I'm not going to comment on that
um very ill advice and H4 by chakra
preventing black from going G5 which
actually was a threat I think
yeah and also discouraging black and
castling although it's still possible
you could still Castle because after
Bishop G5 you have Queen F2 so I would
very much consider castling here for
black can white if you cast a white
Throne oh F3 the C3 Pawn is loose okay
you're being a sneaky guy here that's
right yeah maybe this is not the end of
the story because hero I can take on G4
but I would imagine the black as also
Knight F2 exists here
yeah no knife is great nicely done just
distracting from the bishop you know
what's a funny move if you're five
anyway it does I was just I was just
thinking about this line and then F4
but of course there's Queen takes F2
yeah and then also there are all these
pieces hanging on the you know even
after that line like The Rook takes on
H1 it takes the Knight on G1 oh yeah no
forget it too much is falling what if
you set that up
by okay never mind he goes Bishop B5
and again ding has
a decision on his hands which way does
he hassle
any Castle short yeah cows and queen
side now with the bishop takes D6 it's
like first White then black as those
double pawns there still probably good
for black I just think it's sensible to
cast King's side
somehow you know he's succeeded in
getting his pieces out and he's still in
one piece
and I feel like very subtly the game has
turned a little bit in White's favor and
after Knight E5 for example there are
tactics connected with this move Bishop
G5 and uh you know that's why he put
upon an H4 this is always going to be a
headache for black
so okay how did she play 95 then how
does black attack White's Pawn structure
looks bad but where's the attack going
to come from exactly like you right
where's that inroad you need to make to
really threaten the position I love
Bishop G5 I would play that both I think
it's a very even it's funny yeah I think
it's a good move period but also for
Blitz chess it's just like you you get
frazzled by that idea I don't like F3 at
all I think that's a very
uncharacteristically slow move I mean
first of all he just gives up a pawn and
ding says thank you very much but the
additional benefit of that is that the
queen now has a potential Escape Route
and Bishop G5 now
I mean I I like this move nonetheless
but it's not quite as effective but
Queen E6 Knight F4 and uh but now Queen
G6 and queen H7 maybe just tuck the
queen in
defensive purposes I do get why he
played F3 because after Queen G6 the E4
Pawn was like hanging in some variations
but yeah you could ever afford to take
E4 because the bishop takes H6 and other
similar ideas so I agree with you
completely F3 was slow it was not
necessary to the attack but there still
is potential here because the quote H7
isn't very happy oh yeah Knight H5 here
seems to marry a consideration and then
some sort of Knight F6 sacrifices on
Deck yeah so there's storm clouds
swirling around black skin here without
a doubt
oh there's so many interesting lines
there like Knight H5 a king h8 might be
played and you can still play Knight F6
because the Knight can't be captured but
then a queen just goes to G6 it's like
barely escaping being trapped H5 would
trap the queen if not for Queen takes G5
so it's it feels like one idea is
missing there from being a knockout
yeah and the evil bar I think Bears out
the idea that objectively speaking white
doesn't have enough here and with the
time ticking down I'm definitely
skeptical of
shock's ability to to whip up caterpley
he goes via a different route he goes
like D5 and he's sort of baiting back
into capturing that night which ding
does not he goes King h8
so I could capture that pawn on C7 and
he does
see it's one of those pawns where you
don't really want to capture it because
it opens up the Rooks file but you're
down upon to begin with and otherwise
what are you really going for there's no
Checkmate attack so he takes it he
brings Knight right back I'm taking on
D5 yeah for sure I have six instead by
ding
wow that's a pretty bold move very
weakening yeah the light squares now are
a bit of an issue
I don't know just drop the bishop back I
thought this should be three was more
natural but okay agreed
and now you just take on D5
yeah I mean one of the ideas is Ed
something like night before but you
definitely want to take with a rook on
D5 oh that's beautiful attack though you
went through the rook and D5 and it
wasn't possible when the bishop was
still on G5 we just go back a second
there in the game when the before F6
if Bishop takes D5 The Rook takes 25
that's H6 G5 now because loose that's a
great critical difference that's so so
easy to miss that all of a sudden that
Rook is undefended
and now the bishop is obviously no
longer capturable yeah wow and then that
you do not want to take on D5 with the
pawn that's why I took with the rook in
the game and now white has all this play
against the D6 Pawn isolated in a week
the H1 Rook is going to D1
this is absolutely anybody's game
because that Knight is coming into C4 I
would put no stock in the eval bar here
yeah no I and if agreed and I think it's
time for ding to think about something
drastic like G6 Queen C7 get that Queen
into the attack at all costs
I that's you you can't be slow here he
wants he goes A5 because he's saying I'm
gonna go A4 okay what's your Bishop off
the board
and White's Bishops are like thumbs here
wouldn't I just love a knight to sink
into G6 Black's King is all of a sudden
like the safest piece on the board
White's king is not in any imminent
danger of getting mated but give like a
couple of moves and you know I might
change my mind on that and Rook takes B5
may look like a free Pawn but then black
was A4 anyway just here here take all my
pawns take system then the B Pawn then
the a pawn open those files from my
Rooks I'm gonna go try a Checkmate he
does take on B5 and queen G8 he tries to
activate his Queen but in a slightly
awkward way Rook B7 deserves
consideration but then A4 could come
yeah that's a problem
that is a problem Rook D5 shutting down
the diagonal A4 anyway
transformation here still looking really
good for black yeah this has to be
losing for white White's up a pawn but
the king is so weak for whiteness is
extremely safe it's a tale of two kings
and again it's very important to realize
it's not that mate is coming on the next
move but Black's gonna activate the
other Rook he's gonna take on C3 and
it's only a matter of time before
White's position collapses and the queen
could come in through f8 to A3
and here comes the queen yeah Queen F7
now the queen go to C7 or too many entry
points too many entry points and now
White's starting to lose all of his
Pawns
and this is just clean and there's no
even possible attack for white yeah
those are the most depressing positions
when you're literally when you have no
counter play and you're getting mated 15
Ways to Sunday and I do like to move
King H7 it feels like Ultra nice to
avoid any checks whatsoever and that way
you can oh look it's Queen C6 there's no
paycheck right because the king uh was
over there on H7
okay shock is gonna flag on a low
clearly the position is completely lost
and another weirdly top seed service
game where it felt like shock had had a
disastrous opening he sort of came back
but they never really took his foot off
the gas pedal and I think that was a
pretty Justified result
yeah nice game by day you know we were
saying before we thought it was three to
two in ding's favor it wasn't it was two
to two at the time but it has felt like
Bing has played the better chess thus
far yeah not to take anything away from
mamajarov and some of his games here it
just feels like it's been in ding's
style many of these games where Mom
driven that last game tried to make a
tactical but then he pulled back he went
F3 and that turned the entire game
around where instead of just going for
the brute force method of going for
checkmate he made this com F3 move and
then A2 was snagged and ever since that
moment it felt like Bing had the upper
hand
I agree and I think chocolate is best
um again at the risk of baxi driving a
little bit here uh when I see Shaq
playing that kind of Blitz where he
beats Magnus he doesn't hesitate he goes
for these moves like Bishop G5 almost
instantly his intuition is legendary
just seems like he's hesitating a little
bit in this match uh and his openings
are just a little bit too loose if he
can fix those things but going to the
three minute I think he's going to be in
fine shape
but once again an opening that honestly
plays into ding's hands we have a
Catalan seems like White's gotten a nice
little edge here
looks very nice from White because the
bishop and G2 the Catalan Bishop is open
you can get the C4 Pawn back but black
will often try to stripe with move E5
and yep
and then you do that now it's it's the
time but white doesn't mind because the
bishop on G2 is still strong and you get
a if you cut the board in half uh like
it's an extra Pawn from E2 the E file to
the H file and ooh Bishop B4 that was
nice to spawn as well and here the
Queen's on E5 the queen doesn't want to
be there because it gets kicked back now
just bring the Knight out to D2 which
threatens Bishop takes F6 in some lines
with Knight E4 to follow uh just seems
like white has the easier play between
the two this is actually very important
because because C6 is a very typical
idea for black to blend the bishop but
as it stands the bishop on D6 runs into
trouble another instance of Bishop takes
F6 shark has missed this move once in a
different position and ding has played
Knight T2 and without C6 it's very hard
to get black species out it looks
symmetrical right okay how bad can this
be but after Bishop E6 Queen comes to H4
again Bishop takes F6 is a problem
Black's position is just it's a little
bit too awkward
and people don't really like to see
their pawns double even if Mom and Dad
was allowed it several times today you
don't really want to allow Bishop F6
that hurts the black king Side Pawn
structure so
Queen B5 queen queen then there's C6
well then I thought Bishop takes F6 is
interesting
oh
and I'm going very materialistic here I
mean if you take the queen I'll take and
take B7 this might not be anything
special but if pot is upon us upon oh I
like it and your point as well is that
even though Queen takes F6 would be
possible in that variation like Queen B5
C6 Bishop six Queen F6 because uh the
white Queen's under attack which means
you can't win this bishop on D6 but then
B17 so right you're uh being a thorn in
my side here with your little tactical
that's what I like to hear or I mean
just a general thorn in your side but I
still like Queen H4
I still feel like when H4 is the simpler
approach
but maybe their black is Knight D5 and
the initiative starts to evaporate
can I just say for a second and I have
been listening to your lines here but
there's still 23 plus minutes in the
five plus one segment and I just feel so
spoiled that we have so much more time
left in this match not to be too
wholesome I mean I'm just I
we're like really deep in this match no
we're just getting started here and I'm
really thrilled about it so he does take
on F6 after a long think Queen takes F6
I I don't know what his response to that
right now so he goes for a similar idea
but a different move order and to your
point
um
by the way I don't love this move order
but we'll get to that in a second I feel
like the reason you get the sense that
you know the match is almost done when
it's only just beginning is because
every game is like a journey there's so
many twists and turns in every one of
these games so many different types of
positions and it's so rich it's like a
10 course meal but you know we're only
on the third course but the black caviar
has already been served you know they do
like how exciting you've stepped this up
from the buffet to a 10 course really
nice meal so we're making throttle Step
Up uh well look at this queen takes ding
is making progress on the on Black's
Queen side here so do you go after the
B2 Pawn or that you take the E2 Pawn
right now I would say Rook a I mean
intuitively Rook AB8
looks
looks aesthetically pleasing giving up a
seven and then there's Bishop C5 and the
queen is almost trapped because Queen A5
runs its official takes F2 he's gone
yeah this happened and Dingus just
decided or a shark has just decided to
take on me too
so I like Knight E4 which stops Bishop
C5 uh he you know and attacks the bishop
in D6 and I feel like you take on E2
Knight takes D6 c66 even material but
non-even position because Look whose
Pawn is better it's a two Pawn the
bishop goes to the corner uh this is a
passive as you just did it's running
and again I I just for some reason I
thought Bishop C5 promised more Dynamic
chances I think shock sort of grabbed
that pawn intuitively
and there comes the Apon
and these positions you often see them
being lost in like three moves yeah I
mean practically objectively speaking
rather I'm sure the black has some way
to to you know restructure the defenses
but you know in a Blitz game this is
almost indefensible in my opinion look
at that Queen on A7 guarding the F2 Pawn
not allowing any kind of counter play
connected with the second rank that's
what makes it so depressing for black
and you can play Queen I wouldn't do
this but you could play Queen D4 at some
moment if you felt any danger
centralized attack D6 offer a change of
Queens absolutely play with the super
end game where you're gonna win the D6
Pawn so the a pawn perfectly safe and
rushing up the board the D6 Pawn under
attack and not getting anywhere so white
is just spoiled you need to use the word
we just used before just it's a so many
options here but that's where it gets
difficult on you where like even in this
position do I put my work on C1 do I put
my work on B1 you start burning your
clock trying to find the perfect moves
understanding that you're not in a one
position just yet but you probably have
amazing winning chances
and shark is doing what he needs to do
he's exploiting you know it it doesn't
matter in a certain sense black
not that he has an easy job but there's
nothing else that shot can do he has one
past Pawn he has to push it it's not as
dangerous as the a pawn but white can't
sleep on that pawn either because that
Bishop on B3 is covering the promotion
Square so ding has to be careful he goes
Queen B6 oh that that's such a good
that's it because very nice move it hits
the bishop and forces it away from that
B3 Square
and totally
totally just discombobulates Black's
pieces because now D4 is impossible and
now A5 is possible and the queen got out
of the bronze way so you did everything
at once D4 was such a big threat because
Rook takes F2 to follow like there's all
these like checkmating ideas and the
King could be unsafe so this is a really
precise play by ding here and what do
you even do is black like Rook B2 just a
B2 yeah
but then the queen can move back to C5
for example no not that move now these
moves are are what people sleep on right
Queen B6 you look at that move you press
the arrow button but that is the you
know the marrow that keeps the game
together those are the moves uh that
really distinguish uh these top GMS in
my opinion it's the slow steady subtle
moves that end all of the opponents
counter play uh and make the position
run like a wellow well-oiled machine so
did you like that move I can't tell
our your attitude is not befitting that
of a professional commentator need I
remind you
um you know the kind of role that you're
supposed to be serving here and and the
fact that you were once considered a
role model this kind of honestly you
know this kind of behavior
wow yeah
I just feel just destroyed emotionally
right now I just
I just totally wrecked you using facts
and logic you did so uh I'm gonna
suggest to move Rook D1 put that Rook
back on D1 try to play and stop D4 and
go after the D5 Pawn all at once uh
because I want to play A6 but I can't do
it right now so
wait a minute Robert D4 oh my goodness
did he just bought a D4 he definitely
wanted D4 you blundered D4 and I jinxed
him again
it's always my fault in the end I always
do this I start praising complimenting
the most florid tone and it's called the
nerdinsky Jinx for a reason
so maybe named it after myself yes maybe
she started treating the other players
like you treat me and then they'll play
better chess so badly
missed it missed the opportunity
but I can't believe I mean D4 is really
obvious
it is also so in mom and jar of style
something feels awesome something's
wrong something's just wrong my grf
should not miss the movie for he should
see that moving to sleep and it just
feels like he's getting into his own
head maybe he he's trusting ding a
little bit too much
I don't usually like to psychologize too
much now first of all the game is not
over yet and he sent his H Pawn down the
board to create more chances against
White's King Ding with 20 seconds on the
clock this is anybody's game
no it's I mean this is going to be a
problem what's going on here like the
movie so quickly the Pawns in A7 are the
pawns on C4 for blacks to go back to B7
I think you're gonna win that
oh you're going for the attack I'm going
to time for H3 because Queen E4 is a
pretty big threat yeah I'm gonna Rook B7
just trying to get that pawn as soon as
possible but I agree that you're still
on the lookout for aggressive measures
no but this is definitely the more
circum circumspect move
and there comes H3 so he satisfies both
of both of us
and I would go so far as to think black
here
if of course you can get away with the
Rook takes A7 because then there's gonna
be Rook CA check King H7 and I think
black is fine there yeah black is fine
but you'll trade a pair oh wait there's
quick yeah yeah so you have something
you trade on C8 first but same idea
applies but maybe you should take an A7
with the other Rook for that reason
Works connected
wait a minute you're giving up that rook
and then going Queen F3
that's a crazy idea
three
wait a second that's just mate oh no you
you have Rook HH check
okay he didn't go for it
mommy jar of Misses D4 and sees that
idea we need six
we need a queen H4 check if Queen A6
then there's communities
doesn't work ding with two seconds I'm
really worried
C6 yeah this is yeah now there's another
weakness
uh but that piece are getting traded off
by four but what if you take and go Rook
A2 Rook G2 and then start bringing your
king
whoa he's gonna go he's wait can you get
away with this G4 next king G3 I think
so yeah he got H2 Rook H1
yeah but the king comes in around
through E5 and D4 and I guess it's a
drop
he's
saying it's close but I believe him yeah
G4 and King G3 yeah that was really
precise there by the way
jeez a little too close for comfort but
he's an F4 yeah this is a classic
F2
and we have drawn I I still can't get
over that he missed D4 I know
and that's not one of those things where
you really have to calculate anything
the moment you see that F2 is being
threatened you play that move
so both sides with a mutual blind spot
there that was a weird one
yeah just
it was like even in crazier position
moms are just found like these tactics
so you know he is still on the lookout
for all these lines but it's like a
simple moment I think that's his
business problem today in simple moments
he's just been a bit inaccurate and not
seizing his chances
I agree but like you said finding the
Rook sacrifice where he had a single
queen creating made threats you know he
saw that but he missed E4 and he's got
to fix those he's got to fix the
fundamentals here and if you can do that
I feel like dings definitely giving him
tactical chances as we have a main line
where it goes in here Knight E4 is a
move
I think Knight E4 is actually the most
popular move as of late
and is that as a queen G6 okay Queen E7
I was wondering yeah Queen G6 is also a
move
and so does black just play this very
solidly like Bishop D7 C6 you play it in
that manner and I think most people look
at this like wait don't Grandmasters
always talk about how having the bishop
pair is uh good and there's yes often
the bishop pair is better but look at
White's peace placement amazing in the
center C4 D4 E4 uh in this moment there
could be some Queen H5 type which just
get extremely active so I do like the
look of this position from White's
perspective uh even if there's not too
much happening just yet
yeah I analyzed this a couple of Bishop
B2 yeah that's very deep
does he want to reroute the bishop
somehow to F3
Knight B5 maybe I don't really get there
should be two do you
uh no I I might be three maybe somehow
you need to add the Russian accent here
to better understand that move
no I think that this is not no Advantage
for white I don't know why it is worse
but this doesn't feel like what you
Bishop is coming to C6 the other Bishop
coming to B6 and Bishop d8 that is
that is just crazy and he played it
instantly now if white takes and goes
Brook C7 I guess there was some sort of
Bishop C6 move is this rep or something
I was about to say oh my goodness we're
on the same page
but what what Bishop A5 d8 in a half a
second I mean dingling around is a
brilliant chess player but that is just
that is next level it's obscure I would
answer no to your question but knowing
it's dingler and anything is possible
and as is often the case maybe it's not
the exact position that he knows but
rather the idea occurs in a very similar
position and he kind of took the small
risk and said I'm gonna play it I'm
going to trust that it works here too
but he's not entirely out of the woods
yet no he's not right and he's deep in
thought right now so if that was
preparation
props but now you have to figure out
what to do next and I
you don't want to take that C5 that's
clear yeah and I think a lot of people
would would think wait a minute you
could just take any foreigns to draw
because you have opposite colored Bishop
well not quite not at all in fact after
Bishop takes E4 black is in huge trouble
these Rooks are coming into the seventh
the B7 punt is hanging black is going to
be suffering for the rest of the game
here
yeah I would not take on e4 he might be
calculating that to the end saying all
right I found a way not just in the next
three moves but like 10 moves down the
line I see a way that I can sort of
neutralize White's pressure and that's
what these top players do is they don't
just you know sit and visualize but they
truly evaluate what happens after that
sequence so Bishop takes E4 if he plays
it he's been thinking for what a minute
and a half now it means that he's worked
it out completely otherwise I'll make a
calm move like rookie rookie there might
be 96 so maybe not rookie eight which
maybe have five
I know that's very drastic
so it's very weakening yeah
I think I would
I don't know what to do I'm not well
that's exactly why I'm suggesting a five
because I don't know what to do you're a
brave man I think after F5 I would trade
queens and play Knight C5 for white but
it's hard to suggest anything else
yeah but that'll take and then I'll take
and actually the problem is that
imperceptively White's gotten some lift
for his King so why doesn't have to
worry about the background anymore and I
agree White's gonna get at least one
rook and possibly even two to the
seventh rank I think it's a question
here of choosing the Lesser evil ding
has been thinking for like two minutes
here
yeah you know he doesn't know what to do
and he's trying to work at every single
possibility uh what if he makes is there
a calm move that can be plays a rookie
it I don't like because of 96.
oh then he wants to take an F3
he played it huh
maybe 96 there's Bishop B6 first and
then the Rook can move and take on F3 as
you said so aha
or you could take an F3 immediately no
is there something wrong with this uh it
gives I know it doesn't give any
additional options because 98 you would
take on C5 and black ones a piece right
that's clear so shock might also try to
make a Comm move like H3 or B4 sort of
just improving his position we start
playing this typical Grandmaster cat and
mouse game where both sides make these
small Improvement moves but there's a
lot going on in the position so it's
kind of weird that they're doing that
and there's before
I like the H3 just because in some of
these lines we've been talking about
there's some background issues for white
so I probably would have started with H3
but B4 looks more than reasonable
and
the idea of rookie eight
uh shines through here Bishop B6 and The
Queen Is Now protected and a decision
for white to see trade Queens is equal
Queen D6 maybe that's a little too much
Knight D6 though looks or Knight C5
looks interesting
yeah I would definitely try to trade one
pair of Bishops uh for white for from
Black's perspective you probably want to
keep both Bishops because as soon as
these light Square bishops get traded
that means that white controls the light
squares the Knight can hop to C4 that
Bishop on B6 is not only under attack
but can never attack the knight in the
light squares
yeah you see these end games sometimes
in the Catalan
um and this was a regozen so a little
bit similar but yeah the knights really
really nasty in these types of positions
because there's all these weak squares
on the queen side as you indicated
uh that the Knight can can worm its way
into so objectively it's probably equal
and I think ding will make a draw here
but it is unpleasant
it is unpleasant and there's that love
for the Kings and no background issues
if you take a knight D6 oh I guess B6
Knight C8 you can play A6 because the
bishop on d8 covers the B6 bomb uh and
if white tries to fix the pawns the
black is the very important resource
Bishop E7 if this Pawn on A3 was on A4
then white would have Knight C8 in this
position and all of this has happened
Knight D6 B6
that's so important though like these
are the little things in chess that
really add up right that problem A4 or
an A2
white is just like winning on the spot
but because the pawn is on A3 which
looks good in the initial position right
the A3 Pawn protects B4 but it just
stops one of the other plans and that
allows black to escape here and this is
I was about to say and you'll see you're
drawing the arrows Bishop C7 can black
somehow like play for a win I was
thinking the exact same thing and I
actually am a little surprised at A6 I
think an elegant way to solve this would
have been Bishop C7 Knight P5 and then
Bishop E8 and you can play A6 at your
leisure but I guess ding wants to
play King E7 with Tempo okay yeah I
think black is completely neutralized
why it's initiative and
with some damage on the king side here
black is really the only one who can
fight for anything and when he plays B5
eventually is black those pawns are
stuck on dark squares which in the
bishop if it can reroute itself can
attack
and White's just bitten off more than
you can chew then the Knight could
reroute to D3 or B3
and it could keep the bishop at Bay by
threatening to come to C5 so white
should definitely be able to make a draw
here
you just get the sense that shock has
not been too confident in these types of
positions and one thing to consider here
Dania and maybe it's extreme but if
black can like play E5 and G5 at the
same time there's like potential for
black to Spring free and outside past
pawns you have to be super careful as
white and make sure that you have those
ideas covered because black has the get
the outermost pawns if you look at the
board yes they're double pawns those are
protected but as soon as you can play G5
H5 G4 you can try to make a pawn past
for black
yeah this would be an incredibly painful
game to lose if you're shocked because
he had everything under control he was
pressing
and you know in no Universe could anyone
expect that Ding would turn that
position around now it's way too early
to talk about a lost position but might
be one
that's not the sign of someone who's
happy with his position no he's on
defensive and another thing to note
that's really essential to this end game
is when there are pawns on both sides of
the board the bishop tends to be better
than the Knight so the Knight can attack
you know things on light squares that
the bishop can't defend but because the
pieces need to be spread out a bishop is
a long arranged piece and that could
play to Black's Financial I
I I wish if I were thinking it's from
Blacksburg perspective that the e-pawn
was on H6 because then I could play H5
H4 G4 things like that now it feels like
why is everything under control
yeah and tracker are going out for kind
of forcing things and he's definitely
thinking if how to move like H4 and he
plays it but wait a minute that is
that is a huge risk because now after
Bishop d8 I understand that white gets
the pawn
to H6 but that Bond might become a
weakness and ding decides to get his
King to the king side instead
wow
each floor is bold I think shock is
probably flirting with the idea of still
playing for a win and that could cost
him dearly yeah and how is he gonna win
this game like the king went to E7
everybody King D4 ever this bishop B6
check
so he's going on with his Knight Knight
takes E6 is a threat or is it because G3
could follow in response right and black
has a passport I can't forget about that
I am going to steer clear of calculating
this one I think Bishop B6
just smells right he goes King G6 first
it will I think it'll transpose the same
line yeah
and chakra could play E4 and try to
break apart Black's Pawn chain but the
problem isn't the pawn chain is that the
cheap one might actually promote exactly
E4 open to the G1 exactly
we are now with 25 seconds this is Major
danger the eval bar is not concerned but
I am
Knight G7 is great you're just going to
go five she's three Knight takes a fire
oh Knight H4
and Robert look at this line if King
takes F5 H7 you're going to have a
simultaneous promotion and White's gonna
have some sort of a winning move there
yeah Queen E5 will win the bishop at the
very least but that's probably the
earliest way to win the queen no Queen
five Queen E6 Queen takes B6 is gonna
happen yeah our Queen have fake win H6
same idea yeah same exact thing insane
and shakura's risk pays off he just
needs to play accurately here
uh-huh I think F6 is now forced you
cannot go on to the G file
this is not quite over yet black has
ideas of delivering a Perpetual yeah
there are five million checks available
exactly the King on D3 oh that's a Nifty
check trying to force the king to the
sixth rank
chakra has forced that King
into an inferior position this is given
whites game more real estate and White's
King could aim for B7
and it might just go there right now
King C6 you don't care about the A3 Pawn
C6 well I can take that pawn on A3
because the other pawns are cemented
right A6 B5 it's like not really like
having a passport that's like oh and
there it is that interposes with check
and wins the game and what an incredible
turnaround though for soccer yard who we
were concerned that he was close to
losing the game
but Knights I talked about this
yesterday with Iman when you've got time
pressure there is nothing better than a
knight because of the just constant
possibility of a crazy night Fork that
turns everything around that's exactly
what happened here a huge win Robert of
a shock regards they enter the final
game of the five minute portion and it's
a sign of tremendous strength to be so
resourceful to find these defensive
tactics that keep you in the game
because if we're honest ding was out
playing him in that end game it looked
at first oh yeah it should be nothing
then you're like Wait Almost is winning
with a knight initially then wait a
second black is trying to win and H4 was
really I think not a great move by Mom
jar but he ended up winning the game
because of it so you know it's like
Stephen Curry shooting a 30-footer it's
a terrible shot until it goes in and
then it's a great shot
and then it's a terrible shot when
Jordan Poole tries to mimic that action
right so oh yeah Jordan Poole needs to
you know he needs he needs to pass the
ball a little bit more but uh
uh that's okay he's he's one of my
favorites well look at this position
Mommy here takes in C4 dingling around
plus E4 and E5 I feel like I've seen
many games with being on the white side
of the position just like this and if
you play B5 right now then I think
Knight E4 to G5 and forces G6 and then
you just try to
create an attack against the black king
because he's just trying to run him off
the gym here with H4 I would be up for
that and the thing is black wins a pawn
but has committed himself to the queen
side while white is putting all the
pieces off on the king side
he's gone Knight before instead to which
Dingus responded by trading him going
King F1 now again if white can get
Knight G5 and then all of these
concessions right giving up the dark
squirt Bishop moving the king to F1 all
of that is going to be justified so if
I'm in Yara I'm seriously considering uh
something like Bishop E7 may be followed
by F5 trying to change the nature of the
game he goes at five immediately I like
this decision
is gaining a little confidence here
after that last game Queen takes C4 here
what's what's the big deal you know I
mean like okay white can't Castle which
is unfortunate for him
but doesn't this seem just to be
structurally really good for white
yes but at the same time yeah
you know if the Knight can get to D5 I
think black will stabilize it
I like what Chuck is doing I know this
looks incredibly flimsy but I'm going to
I'm gonna I'm gonna argue that Ding is
gonna let this let this Advantage slip
you know what I'm looking at is he can
do one I really like but I want to play
H4 and then Knight F3 to G5 at some
point it probably doesn't work because
you're not gonna you don't even have to
take me but I want to just like open the
H file up especially you know your king
is on h8 right no that's a lovely idea
and there comes H4 this is just a
multi-purpose move right it's healthy
even if you don't go Knight G5 it opens
up some space
perhaps Bishop H3 and sharkery are King
each that is Knight to D5 King H2 to
connect uh the Rooks as well so
um
yeah Knight G5 it's just not a good move
but it's one of the ideas that I want to
make work at some point of going against
the King on h8
and there there it is King H2 chakra
fulfilling his idea but that doesn't
solve it's not a Panacea getting an i2d5
it's nice but black still has all of
these structural weaknesses the rook's
gonna come to E1 and then E6 spawn is
going to get weak
yeah I guess I was a little over
optimistic I liked the way Shakura was
playing but now I'm seeing that his
position is very much at risk of
collapse so I know this from experience
Dania is I like these positions when I'm
playing them from black and then I
always lose so I'm like maybe I should
stop liking this from the black side
maybe objectively it's just good for
white so I've learned my lesson enough
times for a bit getting punished in
these online list games so yeah look at
how passive black is Bishop D7 Bishop E7
Bishops are supposed to thrive with an
open board Knight C5 here for white
you're at the very least you can take
one of those Bishops
now if you take with a pawn you allow E5
so ding takes with a queen keeping that
pawn on D4 which might look like a
weakness but it's actually a strength
that's preventing black from playing E5
just keeping keeping the clamp going
it's a weak Pawn if you will but it's
making Black's Bishop weak because that
Bishop can't open up without C or E5 and
you're not getting those moves in with
that pawn D4 so I would not trade Queens
he doesn't uh White's King very safe on
H2 blacks came safe enough but in some
potential danger later in the game and
maybe just double Brooks Rook E2 rookie
one Bishop H3 you have time here if you
are dang I love his position
I remember my coaches to talk about
these situations where uh one side has
as a very cool looking or beautiful
looking outposts right so you might look
at this Knight on D5 and say that Knight
is totally unassailable black is doing
great but outposts are among the most
visually appealing or visible features
of the position but they are not
necessarily the most important right so
you can't allow yourself to be fooled by
by appearances and if you look deeper
than that you will see just how many
weaknesses black has and just how
passive the other pieces are so the
Knight on D5 certainly doesn't tell the
whole story I think we get mesmerized by
pieces like that but the action operates
all around it and look in this position
if that Knight in F3 can someone get to
C5 just like the first Knight did that
would be great news and you're pointing
the D3 square of course Bishop D3 line
them up and well it works C I'm
definitely playing Bishop B3 because
you're moving away from your king now
I'm gonna go attack your King well
shaka's gonna throw the kitchen sing at
him on the queen side I think he's
preparing for C5 which is smacks of
desperation but I guess you got to do
what you got to do and then and it's
probably contemplating various
prophylactic measures
as well but I I like Bishop D3 C5 can I
just take on H7 I know you'll take on D4
my queen is under attack but that H7
Pawn is pretty important to your King's
safety I agree but he's gone for Queen
D2
Striker might very well still play C5
that Queen has the potential of swinging
to H I really like the move Queen D2
actually on second thought
if Rook A8 is the move play Then Queen
E2 is just superb right as possible wow
but if Rook C5 like what's your plan
like you're not doubling on the C file
so I wanted to double in the E file
because there's a Pawn on E6 that I want
to go after but he goes Bishop D3 and
he's just now I'm not going out for the
E6 Pawn I'm going after the king yeah no
Queen H6 is now a huge threat black
probably has to bring maybe The Rook to
G8
maybe the queen to d8
guess Rook d8
and a ding move would be something like
rookie two just safeguarding the B2 Pawn
so that the queen would be free to roam
around the king side and I wanted to
play rookie two five moves ago so I will
not complain at all if he plays it now
that's right uh the one thing I will
complain about though is that the
Bishops on D3 which is great but when I
wanted to go rookie to rookie one I saw
Bishop H3 as an option to put pressure
on the pawn on uh E6 so it's like I want
all of it and I can only have whatever
you want the pumpkin pie and the apple
pie and the Cherry Pie just pick one no
I really just one they're all good now
that you're talking about it I'm easy
I'm picking apple pie see how easy that
was I didn't even hesitate very very
easy very easy
and there's working too ding didn't
hesitate either Ricky too
and yeah this is just so hard to play
for black
there's no active try like unless Mommy
will show us something but I don't see
what Mom and Eric knew to make himself
feel better in this position let me tell
you rook ag8 and then once the queen
moves away from H6 Rook takes G3
and that's how black is going to turn
the tables mark my words so I want to
play H5 Knight H4 Knight G6 but as soon
as I play H5 I'm gonna regret it because
that pawn is now on a square that's not
so well defended so
I'm looking at those kind of ideas I
just probably shouldn't I would go Rook
G8 here and in response to Bishop takes
D5 I already think black has these types
of ideas but we'll see
well if you like open up but then their
screen takes F6 in the end white is
still winning there
yeah all right it's a close call but
your point there's ideas of Rook takes
G3 I'm with you there that's something
that I would uh be Keen to avoid and
here Rook a G8 does look like the move
I think you have to do it there is no
threat though because even if I gave you
a free turn Rook HD3 doesn't work
correct so that's the good news for
thing
we in D6 instead getting the queen out
of
the Rooks x-ray but yeah ding also kind
of getting low on the clock and he
hasn't accomplished anything tangible
quite yet you know what I would like for
white as a trade Queen it's not going to
happen because there's no way to do so
but if the queens were off I played 91
Knight D3 Knight C5 so that Knight and
F3 is the problematic piece for white
and that's why H5 Knight H4 came to mind
in Paris like that's the one piece that
isn't doing its job in this position the
pawn and F6 three squares away
completely dominates that Knight all the
Knight is doing is protecting the D4
Pawn which isn't even threatened
yeah and there comes Rook ag8 and
Shakura has somehow gotten all of his
pieces to relatively civilized squares
and there's the ah5 idea that you talked
about
how does black set up rook takes G3
obviously impossible due to checkmate
and he he timed it really well to play
H5 because now the rook's in G8 Knight
H4 Knight G6 is like a smothered
Checkmate idea so black will probably
have to move the Rook away from the G
file at some point
and now Bishop takes D5 is a critical
move that has to be calculated
and I think it works but I'm very much
not positive if I take with the queen on
D5 then okay
yeah but then Bishop takes H5 so ding
doesn't do it he goes Knight H4 but that
also looked good for what I must say
it's like yeah why get I'm saying black
it's an activity but
felt nice anyway but yeah Knight H49 G6
is this is
you know this is low-key like an
unbelievable positional game he is
shutting Shakura down completely and
very few people
in a Blitz game can play this smooth of
a technical game
Overlook the amount of just incredibly
powerful positional moves he's made now
the game is not over yet
but he's just a couple of moves away I
think from from winning this game yeah I
just feel now I felt great earlier when
Mom and Jr played a movie I suggested
that B4 move now I feel great because he
did his little rookie two rookie one
doubling and then one Knight H4 not you
you called it not that I uh said it all
in this order but it just looks perfect
everything's lined up where it needs to
be and now after Bishop G6 or Knight G6
check or something it feels like blocks
I think Bishop G6 is actually the most
precise the E6 if you're on a roll I
agree Bishop takes D5 and Rook takes G3
and this has actually happened but now
Queen takes F6 I think comes to the
rescue
oh my gosh after Rook back to G7 check
you just like rookie five and H6 and you
win a row right and shut everything down
on the Rook
so Rook takes G3 was well I'm proud
because I predicted that Rick takes G3
was gonna happen unfortunately it does
not win the game it simply is a
desperation last second attempt I think
shocker actually missed between the xf6
it's also funny I was having tunnel
vision right something I always tell
people to avoid but I was so focused on
like these Knight G6 Bishop G6 ideas I
didn't see the simple Bishop takes D5
which you had been talking about forever
so
wait a second
wait a second it's not over yet okay
Queen E7 oh Rook takes a four look at
that oh what does white do here you
can't take the queen you're getting
maybe three seconds for ding rookie for
a while you just blunder
but it was wait a minute oh my gosh it
was plus a million so I just was
thinking I'm flexing the position there
was a knight G6 that is one of the
sickest tactics we'll show okay we'll
have to look at it after the game oh my
God this is not over somehow oh my God
he's gonna flag he's got two seconds it
takes me two he's got one second oh
watch out for the meat that's fine Gotta
Move H1 oh my God
h67 what takes a three maybe a flag
check oh my God they're both down like
zero
okay they trade and this has to be over
67 is it winning C4 five and black has
got them contained King d8 Rook C5 and
The Rook is cutting off the king now the
white king should simply Advance all the
way to B4 yeah look at what chakriya is
doing he's trying to get his King to F5
no if it has to be winning if you can
get a pass Pawn even if black gets one
of his oh nice for K5 love that C3 I
love what chakra is doing resilient that
is Texas right there yeah that's
incredible perfect play that's just over
Okay so
let me come back to the moment where so
here
so yeah so after Rook takes a fight in
this no way yes 96 check how sick is
that because okay I'm the first but if I
take because everyone takes H4
right that's Checkmate so that's the
first in the show but I was helpful
because the evil bar is Sky High and I'm
like what is it and Knight G6 check the
Rook can't take and if the Rook can't
take on G6 that means the white King has
an escape on the G file and so if you
take on G6 with the pawn queen takes D6
no Rook H4 Checkmate because the king
can go to the chief that is and if you
take with a bishop it's the same thing
because working G3 no discovers nobody
is seeing that with three seconds on
their clock in the midst of this really
intense uh match but what an a tactic
that would have been dingly Wren still
gets the full point he put a nice game
there done as we go to break what do you
think mama jarv needs to do to score
back in this match I think the opening
is actually really important because I
feel like shocker is getting a little
bit into his Groove tactically speaking
I mean even in this game like the way
that he managed to create tactical
chances is pretty incredible so I think
you know he's outsmarted ding tactically
at a couple of junctures but he keeps
getting dragged into these positional
games where he slightly worse got no
active counter play and essentially ding
in is totally unmatched in his ability
to squeeze advantages so I think for
shock he's got to be more careful in the
opening he's got to try to get more
tactical positions even if he's still
objectively worse we'll see if he
manages to do that we've got 60 Minutes
of three minute chess coming up this has
been an awesome match so far absolutely
we'll be right back for more from this
dingley Wren chakra mom and jar of match
here in speeches championship
foreign
[Music]
chess.com is your exclusive twitch home
for the video feeds for this year's
feeding World Championship join us that
will be me five Anna carwan Danny wrench
for the best coverage around as we watch
this year's players the defending
Champion Magnus Carlson and Challenger
Jana Paul Machine Battle for the title
the feed a world championship coming in
November to chess.com but Dania we're in
the midst of this match ding me Ren with
the lead over Shakura mamajarov
the smarter chest predictions say that
Mama Jarvis a slight favorite in the
three plus one what do you think about
that
I think that's reasonable I think that
shockery are is you know a little bit
more experienced and I can't say that
time management has been you know I I
can't say that either side has had
clearly Superior time management we've
had a lot of time scrambles and I mean
it's a complete toss-up but if I had to
go with somebody as a slight favor I
would agree with uh the assessment of
chakra as as The Slight favor but again
I think it's going to come down to his
opening choices can he play more solid
but at the same time can he manufacture
and get the kinds of positions in which
he excels out of the opening
particularly with black and what's
interesting is we've seen dingly Wren
jump out to leads on the clock in the
five plus one portion but as history has
taught us the players who tend to be
really fast in the five plus one out of
the opening somehow slowed down in the
three plus one and Mama jar has shown I
think better skills like when it's pure
mouth skills in the bullet scrambles I
think that Mom and Jeff has the upper
hand so the shorter the temperature roll
the better it should be for Mama jar but
don't count dingly run out like in that
last game it was getting a bit
nerve-wracking for him and yet he still
was able to convert a win in a rook
First bishop ending so I don't know who
to predict as the winner in this
individual segment but all I know is
we're gonna have some great fun as the
time Patrol shortens and here we go
indeed it's only a one point match
chakra are trailing by a point and he
goes for the king's Indian attack once
again
we saw that happen once and Shakura
didn't really get an awe-inspiring
position this time he goes D4 sort of a
reverse grunfeld type
E5 and I don't know much about this this
line yeah it looks really good for black
because of these two Central pawns right
black has an extra Pawn the center but
look at how quickly that white gets the
chop of those pawns d5's under attack by
the bishop and the queen now the Knight
joins the party if you ever push D4 then
the bishop is open on G2 so that's why
H6 is played which defends D5 because
Bishop F6 Knight F6 the queen joins in
the defense that's three black pieces
defend the pawn to three white attackers
that's not enough attacking white will
need to play Queen D3 Rook D1 and maybe
F4 at some point as well it's a very
complicated start to this game but I
like this see this is exactly what I was
talking about this is not uh too risk I
mean shotgara is playing reasonable uh
solid well-justified moves but he's
gotten the kind of imbalance that I
think he really excels in and he
definitely has the initiative I mean it
might very well be that he's not better
uh those two things are not mutually
exclusive he might even be slightly
worse but he could still have the
initiative for the time being let's see
how ding handles the question of a
center
so he had to like D4 the bishop on G2 is
very happy about that uh Knight E4 would
be the move that I would play and then
try to play C3 next or maybe F4 you have
different options trying to Chisel at
Black's Pawn structure indeed Knight E4
looks very natural he also has a check
on B5 but that might not work out
concretely due to Bishop D7 blocking the
D file in the C3 Knight is going to be
lost I think he's probably calculating
that though Bishop takes B7
another interesting move wow spicing up
the position even further what's going
on up to DC
yeah yes maybe DC there's like Queen B5
well Jane doesn't bother with it he just
castles and says go take my Rook I don't
care I'm gonna have Bishop H3 all day
oh that looks amazing for black I mean
you don't even need to take the work on
H1 like oftentimes you just say my
Bishop in a relatively close position uh
for the Rooks the Bishops can Thrive so
now the Rook is going to B8 we see a
trade and white is up a pawn so even if
the eval bars is black is slightly uh
better it's to be preferred I I think
from a practical point of view I like
the way that Mom and jar is playing
for sure but Deng has sort of maintained
his composure here C3 a move that you
mentioned a while ago black and that
would take on B3 twice and get a
position with opposite colored Bishops
I'm not sure what to make of it
think goes for it probably some sort of
a draw here is on Deck but
if it's hard to say which Bishop is
better queen of five if the pawn were on
G6 then Bishop D5 would be such a sweet
move uh right because if Queen takes q6
but the pawns on a nice protected Square
yeah it's not there so
now black has to be careful because this
idea of when Queen F5 Bishop E4 White's
got full domination over the light
squares
and we've already seen a couple of cases
where despite the natural draws
Tendencies of opposite colored Bishops
the side which has Square domination is
often calling the shots but maybe ding
can squeeze in E4
yeah this this should be a draw
Rook C8 E4 is an important move at some
point because if you love Bishop D5 and
then white to start pushing the pawns
the bishop D5 is really strong there uh
so E4 just tried to trade things off he
starts with Rook C8 and yeah this is A1
now this just
peace offering Bishop F1 total
liquidation
and even in this position
for a second I thought somebody resigned
because I'm not used to like draws being
offered at all
and I just came back from the U.S
Championship where draws were not
allowed
and so but no drivers agreed which is
totally reasonable
Anna Blumenfeld
well we saw an earlier game where I
guess it wasn't in the Blumenfeld but it
was a similar Dynamic but shafrier had
the white pieces in that game and so now
it's reverse colors Mama jar was taking
an approach of very tactical play but
he's so good at three minutes he's more
accustomed to that time control and
dingley ren sitting and thinking in the
early stages of this game too second
game in a row where ding has gone Think
Tank first
that's right and he accepted the
blumenfelds but we all know how
dangerous this opening can be if white
is not incredibly precise in his peace
Arrangement black is a very easy piece
set up in his own writing Bishop D6
Bishop B7
and I like what ding is doing here E4 is
striking in the center and maybe even E5
should be considered trying to punish
black for you know clearly very flimsy
play yeah E5 Knight G4 I don't know the
consequences because E5 Pawn might be
lost but look at how many weak squares
the King on E8 can be attacked but yeah
Knight G4 played is the movie that need
to be played and then I think Knight G5
oh Mike what is happening what is it
it's a knight E5 94.
okay 94 has been played a little bit
less insane and obviously he's inviting
white or black to take the pawn now
there's a funny move here I'm not saying
this is gonna happen but Knight takes E5
is possible and after Bishop takes E5
you have Queen H5 and you're gonna lose
one of the miners here
that's actually a nice clever sequence
uh one of those situations where maybe
white goes up a pawn but black has the
bishop pair and especially his potential
Bishop pair with that C8 Bishop going to
B7 which I probably do right now unless
I'm missing something tactically
speaking and it looks like
the dynamic chances are nice for black
he's taken on E5 though which I kind of
ruled out in my mind yeah I don't like
this at all
Dingo and queen H5 check maybe he won't
even bother taking the C5 Pawn that's
not the prize
that he has his eyes on instead he goes
for the complete light Square domination
his King is safe he's gonna Castle black
has this incredibly weak Pawn on E6
taking on E5 Robert I agree I think that
was a really poor decision by Shaq
because the material is even but that's
not what you played when you play a
Gambit and then restore material
equality like right away there's often
some kind of backfiring situation and
right now you see the black king won't
find shelter C5 is weak E6 is weak white
is developing quite naturally and I
think this is going to be a struggle for
Mama job I don't even know what he
should do here I mean he should probably
Castle but ding has a gazillion helpful
helpful improving moves into Rook D1 can
you just take on C5
you absolutely can he goes Rook E1
yeah I think there was no reason not to
take on maybe G6 but there's Queen F3
and the A8 Rook is loose oh hitting
we're kind of a nice
okay Shockwave G6 anyway Queen H3 is now
very much
possible hitting E6 and played Black's
position is just so riddled with
weaknesses if Queen B6 white could even
go A4 A5 uh trying to tickle black from
the queen side
this is not pleasant uh
geez what a disaster and look at the
time situation not my mediara's friend
either
I honestly might just give up the E6
Pawn because I honestly May resign
even even though it costs you a pawn
that gives you flexibility for the rest
of your pieces so I I feel like you know
they're gonna work to eat at some point
things could be improving for black even
though the time and the material
are not good now this is just another
thing fine performance oh get me away
from here get me away from here E5
opening up this bishop the queen could
even come back to H6 or queen G3
and White's just got absolute positional
dominance Queen B3 is also interesting
I love Queen G3 just attacking upon I
don't see how black can defend it
we've seen shot create chances in these
kinds of positions but
right now I'm struggling to see how
that's going to happen
and wait a minute ding really quickly
kind of traded his Bishop
so does he see just that deeply here
that the C5 Pawn is just falling and
it's I mean it's another obstacle Bishop
position if I'm starting to get a little
bit skeptical Robert I mean giving up
that Bishop I think should only happen
if you're winning material and like you
said that Bishop slices through the
Queens I think he just underestimated
this idea of Bishop B7 and Bishop or
queen D5
and somehow my midi Arab is kind of back
from the dead here
yeah there was definitely a simpler
approach it didn't give black these
attacking chances and queen E6 plays
Bishop takes four
okay but that bishop and D6 is terrible
some bold positional decisions are being
made very quickly here Robert I mean
H4 now looks pretty interesting or maybe
Queen maybe back out to D5 maybe F4 can
you get away with that
and if I take just Bishop takes The Rook
spin on F7 yeah true but then maybe I
can take on F4 and go Queen D7
okay here's rookie one okay
take the pawn back okay yeah I didn't
have this he has more violent intentions
than you do yeah wait a second now is
there not
thinking of some crazy sacks like Queen
takes D6 it doesn't work
no Queen E8 check with a move but it
won't work out so F3 was
F3 just wins Bishop takes H2 is coming
this is unbelievable
and white is paying the direct price for
giving up his light spread Bishop but
the eval bar I can't read the exact
number but it doesn't look like
completely winning for blacks maybe
there's something that keeps white
afloat here F2 checking Bishop to King
H1 that's the only move I see that stops
both threats at the same time right it's
a slightly sad move but thing plays it
he has to
and now shakurai with a decision on the
San Francisco F2 or F takes G2 both
moves looking pretty tempting
um and The Rook is hanging on dead so
don't forget about that but
there might be Queen F7 check or is Rook
takes F2 right away oh this is getting a
little this is getting crazy Bishop back
to f8 hitting the queen
now simply rookie oh Queen D5 that's a
nice move I love that move I love the
simplification black's got a million
passers here and this is just over that
content Community too it's resignable
what an incredible turnaround I really
like how Mama jar played that open not
sorry not the way he played it at every
moment but I love his choice because he
is taking it to ding in the shorter time
Patrol saying as you said in those
critical moments under the duress with
the clock ticking down he has shown a
propensity to just find these wonderful
tactics so I think Mom and Dad was doing
the right thing against ding
he absolutely is and and ding I mean
something just happened there when he
took that night on F7 I mean there was
no need to transform the position no
need to give up the bishop
and I think dingo just got a little bit
impatient there maybe got a little
nervous as his time was taking down
whatever it was Muhammad yarab equalizes
the score that was a big win and again
he goes for one of these super
unbalanced positions this is kind of
like a game but I mean if black takes on
C5 and black is going to be up a pawn
but
White's got very significant pressure
here I've seen this a couple of times
recently actually so have I it's white
gives upon the queen has done all sorts
of dancing for black right Queen B6
Queen B2 Queen C3 Queen C5 how many
times is that queen move I lost track
and the point is though that white has
gained time and gained open space for
the pieces is it fully Justified
I'm not probably not I kind of like
having the extra Pawn but maybe there's
more than meets the eye at least my eyes
my all four of them initially because it
seems that black should be solid given
that the pawn structures sound casting
kingside doesn't look risky at all for
black uh the lights where Bishop won't
get out that's not easy for black to
accomplish but other than that I think
that it's an extra bomb
it absolutely is and shocker are taking
a very long think here
C takes D5 is what he decides on and
taking back with a pawn which
I thought maybe Queen takes D5 was
possible as well
and
yeah a lot of possibilities here for
wedding go Bishop D4 he can Castle
you can even go something like Knight D4
God these positions are so it's so hard
to make heads or tails of these
positions particularly in a three minute
game it goes Knight D4 and I think his
idea is that if black castles he wants
to take and go Rook C1 yes
although that obviously comes with
certain risks giving up the light squirt
Bishop but concretely I think that works
out so maybe things should take this
opportunity to go Bishop D7 I'm not sure
his Queen could get trapped though
well that would be something of the
queen on C5 was trapped there because
there's no D6 and The Rook on B1 makes
Queen B6 difficult there is the A3
Square I think there's just enough
squares for the black queen he castles
instead of Bishop D7
right and Mommy jar of playing flexibly
here Rook C1 now white as a choice
of which piece to capture on C6 with
I'm I don't know what you said taking
the bishop takes some Knight takes yeah
and if Bishop A6 you have to be very
careful about Rook C3
disattaching the queen from the bishop
that is a big threat here
this just looks now great for white I
I'm reading my words I was like oh black
upper Pawn looks good and now I'm like
oh this looks terrible what was Black
thinking getting into this opening what
about Bishop G4
Bishop G4
oh that might lose a piece knight takes
C7 look at this and Bishop takes F6
that's slicing through a Black's
position
that's a problem there is Queen E6 there
but I guess you have F3 and then yeah
you're gonna win a piece so okay so
rookie defending the bishop which makes
sense in the context of the threat
now why can't Castle very easily I don't
know if I like Rook C3 there
I feel like he rushed that just a little
bit
yeah because you just lost the
opportunity to Castle so what do you
even do is white right now because you
don't want to take on E7 just a lot of
Rook takes E7 because the queen protects
the Knight on F6 no doubled F politics
exactly the queen is saving the day no
soup for you now Queenie 2 is often the
problem solver in such situations but
not here I mean black could even trade
Queens black could take on A2 it's
incredibly flimsy I think Shaq is
regretting
seriously regretting going Rook C3 that
kind of did Black's bidding for him by
sending the queen back to A6 where it
prevents gasoline and he goes Queen C1
which does threaten Knight takes E7
followed by Bishop takes F6 because the
queen on E6 is not able to defend the
bishop run C8 so there are some things
that need to be worked out from Black's
perspective here uh I was thinking
Bishop f8 but then Bishop takes F6 does
worry me so I I don't he played it it
does not worry dangling run though
I'm just going to take credit for it I
said Bishop fa right there was no one I
didn't know there was no there was
nothing after that you didn't use that
Bishop f8 exactly that's all that was
said Bishop of faith I didn't hear
anything after that yeah it is fasting
though because there's a doubled
isolated F pawns but the problem is that
white king is stuck in the center
because the queen on A6 can't Castle
through check your point of Bishop B4 it
looks like a great move now uh it's
doing just so much more patient than I
am though he goes Bishop D7 Rook City
accumulates I mean he he just makes all
the improving moves first queen takes A2
nothing wrong with just snagging a
little Ponsky there
but now he goes Bishop before
and just Rook takes C8 White's hanging
by a thread and maybe not even by a
thread it was a piece Queen B2 Bishop C3
and yeah
or maybe take on D2 first and then go
Rook suit too it doesn't matter
it's resigns wow what a win for ding
so I knew black was doing well though
from the very beginning the opening you
know I thought that black was solid and
strong and that played out
gosh this has been such a close match
back and forth they go
and another Blumenfeld if it ain't broke
don't fix it that's a pretty good
strategy to adhere to this time Bishop
G5 by ding different way of
trying to neutralize the Blumenfeld he
declines it he doesn't take the pawn on
B5
in fact he sacrifices upon of his own
potentially Knight E5 wow
very unusual if I'm not mistaken when I
made my final I am Norm this was the
opening that I played from the white
side
against
it wasn't against struck around was it
no it wasn't but I'm trying to remember
it now uh what the person's name was but
uh either way like it's a very rich
opening where look at Weiss Center C4 D5
E4 all looks good black has the bishop
pair but because white controls a lot of
the space the Knight on B5 is active
they're not an A6 is just a defensive
piece it's just a bit uncomfortable here
to to deal with and that's why G5 was
played that's V and Kettle the bishop oh
not so fast an id6 check might be an
issue so it's
[Music]
this looks way too loosey-goosey you
know 96 check first all right I don't
know if it matters E5 and Bishop between
seven bit Queen A4 is coming I mean this
is terrible
I mean you could just
put black in a sarcophagus if you want
with Knight takes eight and D6 some
combination of these moves have to be
winning the Evolve our concurs no and I
think ding senses that Mom and Yara has
has completely misplayed this opening
I'm worried that Mom and jar of Might
tilt yeah this game kind of smells like
a little bit of film now he's not lost
totally lost yet and we've seen him
climb back from these kinds of positions
Bishop D3 very calm move and I think
what he's doing is he's inviting my
major to Castle in which case he's going
to build up a little battery here
and let's see come out with jar of does
Castle
so many options with Queenie too talking
to Bishop X Queen E4 is even more
menacing threatening quinities you have
a Checkmate and D takes E6 The Rook on
AIDS loose this is what about F5 though
right now what about a five yeah
what about F5 might just be a good
choice then you can't play G4 after F5
yeah I mean everything is terrible here
but I'm just trying to buy myself some
time and get my knight back to C7 and
you know that's how these recoveries are
made
that's true I'm just trying to Hype him
up oh if you stop some ideas right you
you may allow others but it makes
White's life much more difficult so F5 I
think you have to play otherwise you're
just gonna get crushed
although you can meet Queen E4 with F5 I
suppose but maybe F6 even more miserable
I have six no no I like it because of
your point right at F5 you can take
ambassant regardless so F6 eject of six
is just a transposition there and
there's no G4 at least for white to like
immediately channel the eval bars and
Rook B8 is just not concerned evenly I'm
just gonna just gonna make improving
move on the Queen's side he was
concerned about Queen e4redonia so he
doesn't want his Rook to be hanging in
the corner oh
so Queen E4 now he wants to play F5 and
ding
something oh wow he castles himself
okay oh okay can you just put Knight
takes A7 instead of gasoline
just snag upon and then come back to B5
looking goon yeah absolutely it's just a
hanging Pawn
yeah
no they don't just lie by the side of
the road
cannot fault him for castling very nice
move
good that's a very dangly around move
just eliminating any risk that could be
associated with the King being in the
center
and you know what what is terrible about
Black's position is that when your
position
is horrible both tactically and
positionally that's when it's time to
get concerned like when your opponent
has both positional dominance and an
attack
you know that's when you got to start uh
starting to start praying you can't take
it oh my God hey so you think of the
real queen H7
now the evil bar is not showing as
overwhelming of an advantage as I would
imagine here oh come on this hat this
has to be this has to be totally winning
nit six Queen E7 Maybe
maybe Queen E7 Holding On by
with the hair imagine chin I thought it
was a 151 but there's not he's taken on
D5 and Knight F5 looks really strong
and then if I've wins at least in
exchange right
yeah but I guess Rook takes a five
Bishop takes F5 and somehow black is
still in the game DC4 and black gets
that pawn Phalanx on the queen side look
if black can stabilize the situation
somehow on the king side
he's gonna have quite a few past fawns
there on the other side of the board
that's true because Queen F5 Queen F6
you do not want to trade Queens even
though white is technically ahead
material the bishop on G7 is a
Powerhouse
that's right
yeah so Bishop takes F5 looks like the
most natural but now I think my major
should capture on C4 he does
yeah he won of course this should be
lost
but
D6 I guess nah I think it's hard to see
The Knockout right we're looking to
position the eval bar is really high the
players don't have access to that so
they're trying to figure it out but if
I'm a mom and Joe I'm like well this
looks better than it was before I have
some long-term Chances with those the
Phalanx of Pawns there C5 C4 B4 if the
Queens could magically disappear then
black has serious chances
right now there are some crazy ideas
with Bishop takes it Queen takes it and
rookie seven maybe oh ding playing a
very patient move but is it too slow
this allows Mama Dr to bring his Queen
and going back to D7
maybe my major should go back to da
I like going to you yeah that's the big
difference though by having the Bishops
being traded that Queen F5 queen of six
which is what black wanted at least the
queen could oh my God he repeats what
I mean I guess Queen G4 there maybe
Queen C6 that is shocking and he
repeated quickly too he didn't really
take his time
looked like he was just scared of wax
Pond pods
what an insane comeback how did Mommy
giraffe save that Robert that was crazy
he just stayed afloat I mean there was
no clear path to victory for white and
that is surprising though because I
think we Ren had a great position I'm
sure he knew it but at that specific
moment I get why he would make that draw
because it was starting to look shaky he
didn't have a clear-cut way to break
through to attack the king and if he
can't attack the king but he was the one
in trouble based on all those Pawns of
the queen side
that does make sense and one of the ways
in which this match is similar to
yesterday's match between Geary and Duda
is that to my knowledge neither side has
led by two points by more than one point
um and that's the ultimate sign of a
close match where where neither side can
gain any separation
that's that's correct important for Mom
and Dad not to lose this game I think
well he's doing these openings that I
don't love at this uh sort of like
benoni style position for white the
benoni is not good for black and there's
a reason for it the structure isn't good
not just like the tempo this is like one
of these situations where you know
Knight takes E5 they go 97 and then
reroute the Knight to C5 and E5 Knight
C5 Black's play is very very
straightforward here and I've seen some
games where white just loses this in
like five of those like E5 Knight C5
Bishop F5 and White's position kind of
collapses and here you can start with
Knight C5 because Knight D3 is such a
big threat and then you play E5 next and
the position Bishop F5 to follow
[Music]
yeah D3 and here comes E5 I think
I guess B4
the problem is before Knight A6 you have
to play B5 otherwise you lose a pawn oh
God and then the Knight just comes back
to C5 and you're even worse off than you
started with that's why right because A6
like black can just open the queen side
at some point and
uh this is not good shock needs some
sort of a creative defense maybe Knight
C2 Bishop F5 Knight B4 but then Black's
gonna play A5 I just don't see it
I think you often have to resort to
playing Bishop F1 when Bishop 5 is
played but that's your best piece Bishop
won the long diagonal and that's the
thing about this Knight on C5 it defends
B7 so your Bishop is free to move from
C8
yeah and when you I think when you have
a good knowledge of some of these
openings there's these moves that are
kind of bellwethers like if you have to
make this move it almost always means
the opening has gone wrong and in the
benoni I think the sort of the
Bellwether move is Bishop F1 or Bishop
f8 if you have to do that that almost
certainly means that none of your active
plans have come to fruition now that's
not to suggest that white is losing or
anywhere near losing ding still has to
finesse this
uh to a victory but this is not what my
major had signed up for
being just so solid B6
strengthening the Knight on C5
uh it also allows for
like take a dream on A5 A4 at some
moment look at that night on C2 then I
could go to D5 right if you could get
just a free turn hey come on ding please
don't take me I'm just gonna play Knight
B4 93 I come in peace I come in peace
I'm not really trying to do anything you
don't have to always take free Pieces
come on we have three
no this now it's just completely
dominated right there's the pawn three
scores away there's a pawn D4 for good
measure taking away E3 and G6 allows
Bishop H6 at some point because the
bishop on his current diagonal staring
into its pawn bishop H6 eventually is an
open diagonal to work with now white can
finally drag this Knight to an outpost
and he does the B5 Square though is not
necessarily the greatest Outpost in the
world but at least it's something at
least the Knight isn't dangling under a
speed but Rook B6 Swinging The Rook
along the sixth string can potentially
prepare an E4
I don't know I I didn't like I didn't
like A5 I didn't either there was no
need to give away that square but I do
like H5 so I didn't like the queen side
upon the rest now like the king side one
because uh it gives you attacking
chances you can play Bishop G4 now you
can play G5 after Bishop H6 and The Rook
on B6 perfectly placed to go to G6 in
the near future
and ramadir decided to withdraw the
queen back to D1 I like that move
the Eva bar didn't though
and I guess ding should very much
consider some some sort of crazy G5 move
because white skin could end up in huge
trouble I mean white speeds are all very
passive Queen takes H5 there's Bishops
goodbye Queen oh but isn't there Bishop
H3
he's played G5 by the way I guess takes
HG and then you can leave the bishop on
H6 we'll cross that bridge if we get
there he's taken on G5
and his mommy jar Really Gonna Take This
Pawn
yes because it looks worse if you don't
okay he did but
it does look worse if you don't because
ding is going to play H4 at some point
Swinging The Rook to G6
yeah I would start with Rook G6 now I
don't I don't want to trade on e4
because it brings a rook up unless he
has this one's F5 same page there's no
reason to bring the Rook up unless F5
was the movie you want to play and he
does and H very concrete approach to the
positioning yeah this is looking
destructive the Knight got to B5 that's
the only active piece white has the only
one and it's not doing anything
this reminds me of this game that I
often show my students burmackin against
Carlson it was a young young Magnus game
where Magnus says something similar he
creates a weakness on this precise
square and bermakan spends four moves
excitedly getting his Knight to that
square and the point I'm trying to make
is that even when you get your knight to
The Outpost it's not actually doing
there so an outpost is not a guarantee
that a piece actually fulfills a role
agreed and we talked about it does
fulfill a role well let me remember the
night on D5 and the previous one of the
earlier games you're talking about like
it looks so aesthetically pleasing but
then it just kind of sits there that
energy five can't go anywhere useful now
blacks up an exchange now the rook's
swing to attack the king he takes F4 if
Queen F4 there's Rook F6 rook f8 and now
Queen H3 just bring your queen in and
deliver a Checkmate this is just Rook
gonna trying to calculate Rook G2 but
probably no need for that rookie two I
think also wow that's a really nice move
but I wasn't sure that it was working
ghost Queen H3 and as long as the king
could hide on H7
what a move that's a good attempt right
there I love it that's a good attempt
right there you actually have to try it
it's not dirty I mean maybe it is a
little dirty but you got to try it how
many times have we seen people just sort
of automatically move the king in such
situation no but but that that's a good
sign for Mama jaro that he played that
move I know it may seem like a joke and
he trolling and this is the halfway
point so they're gonna take a break but
I I actually really like that he's doing
that because it shows that he's willing
to do whatever it takes to win a game of
chess and his play has not always been
convincing I mean we know what Mom and
Jarvis capable of he was the number two
player in the world he was the person
who broke Magnus carlsen's unbeaten
streak he is so darn phenomenal when he
is in shape but right now it doesn't
feel like we're getting the mom and jar
of that we've become accustomed to and
so just the fact that he's willing to
maybe look a little Silly by playing
Queen D7 check it just shows that he's
gonna do whatever he has to to stay in
this match
like he we've seen flashes of Brilliance
but not to keep harping on the opening
choice but ding has just done a better
job in the opening he's played more
solid chess and I think he's built the
first two-point lead of this match so in
the second half of the three-minute
portion chakriar has a pretty tall task
ahead of him he can't let this get out
of hand ding is clearly in good form and
on the other side of this break we are
going to see if the sort of chakra yard
that beats Magnus Carlson is going to
make an appearance or if ding is going
to continue his solid and masterful
playing can't wait to find out we'll be
back soon
foreign
[Music]
has an aggressive intuitive style he has
a good feeling for chess especially when
he plays with the initiative and he
likes to put pressure on his opponents
he's just overall confident and full of
ideas he can play extremely well in it
and if he comes at his very best then
maybe he can play better than Magnus
and we are back Donya it is a close
match even though ding Loren has built a
two-point lead I think that Mom jar of
has plenty of chances left the bullet
portion in particular but I have to say
I've been very impressed with the way
ding the runners played like he's been
controlled he's made a draw by
repetition in the position that the eval
bar was saying he was still in better
shape so I just feel like he's been
controlled and that's playing to his
benefit against somebody as well as a
wild style like Mama giraffe
I think you hit the nail on the head and
I think that you know one could argue
that Ding is not going to win any
brilliancy prizes for any games he's
played thus far but that's not the point
of the match the point of the match is
to win and he's exploited a lot of the
opportunities that shock has given them
he's played really well in the opening
and this is a really big game Robert
because dang is the white pieces if he
can win another one and get this lead up
to three that's when things start
getting pretty concerning that's when
you start thinking about you know
pulling away so in my view this is a
turning point game right here
and we see a pretty calm opening uh the
move Bishop the Bishops for white out
and active and it's such a weird opening
down here because black looks like he's
like four Tempe down and yet it's not
that bad usually for black
no but I'm a little surprised that B6
generally black plays B5 in these types
of positions but I know very little
about you know Queen's Gambit accepted
structures
there's sacrifices also that kind of are
hanging in the air on E6
probably not yet but if black plays B5
I would very seriously contemplate
Bishop takes C6 yeah if you're gonna
force my hand or I want to do that
anyway or Bishop B2 Bishop F3 and if you
get rid of black star light squared
Bishop then all these weak squares along
the long diagonal could
could come back to buy black I agree and
Mom jar is now thinking he is just under
dingley runs time plenty of time left in
this game but still it makes me a little
nervous for him that he spent
30 seconds and played Bishop E7 like
he's he's sensing at their tactics
Bishop takes E6 for example uh is going
to be something he needs to look out for
for a large proportion but there's Queen
D5 in the end a lot of these very
interesting Bishop E6 takes Knight takes
E6 with a fork but Queen D5 threatens
the Knight threatens Checkmate you don't
get that Rook on f8
that's a great point and so for that
reason I was considering the position
purely positional idea of uh getting the
bishop to F3 on your own volition and he
does just that my media arev instantly
responds with Knight D5 but still Bishop
F3 creates quite a bit of pressure down
this long diagonal black can do the same
thing but obviously it's not quite as
effective because White's got that
development advantage and you can use it
uh to neutralize kind of black side of
the bargain here this is very unpleasant
for like very unpleasant because if
Knight D7 that runs into Knight C6
you're kind of paralyzed here and here's
our favorite move shockery heart's
favorite mover K7 again didn't turn out
well the first time Robert no I did not
and I think he wants like
I just don't know what he wants Bishop a
doesn't change anything or solve
anything so he's protecting his Bishop
so his Knight can move and then I just
want to move anywhere from D5 that's the
news it wants to be so maybe maybe you
just play Knight D7 but Knight C6 is
going to be an unpleasant ending like it
went down the line like the Queens get
traded having all the control over the C
file and those squares just if B5 I mean
maybe he wants to be six square for the
Queen Bishop A8 he's sort of shuffling
his pieces back and forth his position
is already hanging by a thread I mean
without this Knight on D5 the game would
be over so he better keep that Knight
firmly and sconced on and out on The
Outpost
gosh White's position is brimming with
life it's like a bustling Venetian
bizarre you know it's like Bishop on B2
and knights in the center and Black's
position is like a you know I don't know
I guess abandoned strip mall somewhere
it's it's not good uh it looks awkward
he did stop a knife from coming to C6
right he's overprotected the square so
Knight D7 next is possible
um and probably should be played right
now
but he played H6 instead
yeah I know there are no bazaars in
Venice so
point taken are there are there zero I'm
sure there has been a Venetian Bazaar in
the history there there it goes just
don't let anybody take away your great
exactly
now Queen h5s
sorry no
why why are you apologizing I must know
I feel like I feel like Dane might be
sinking under the weight of just this
sheer amount of tempting continuations
he has because imperceptibly he's gone
under a minute
so Queen G4 threatens all sorts of
checkmates as well
where is mate there has to be something
there right
some sort of Knight takes c66 Knight F6
but as commentators we can just throw
out a bunch of sacrifices unfortunately
for Diggy has to actually calculate them
and finally mamajaro's night has made
its way to D7
wait a minute is there not Knight C6
here Bishop takes C6 Bishop D4 oh it's
beautiful that's really boom boom boom
and if the queen moves or Queen's
overloaded but does Queen B7
Bishop takes A7 oh there's no like I was
trying to move my knife you're trying to
move your knight but I could always sack
on C6 if need be I think he's
calculating Knight C6 and I think he's
gonna play it in about two one now ah uh
oh he's got he's done 15 seconds or even
if he's got a new material I'd have
three no I thought that would be six he
goes up maybe there was something that
scared him off there but either way you
can't afford to be down a minute against
mamajarov no this is shock's chance to
turn this game around and he's worth a
very very least to hold a draw I think
that if white isn't careful black could
end up being on the better side of this
so Rook C8 good
and a large reason why Donya is night
before we'll hit the A2 Pawn right white
Pawn structure is a little bit more
vulnerable to the pieces immediately
than black says because the A6 Pawn is
hard to get to
the Venetian Bazaar has closed down and
now we've just got a pretty colorless
end game by the way that's another thing
I've noticed ding I think does really
well he senses when the game is starting
to slip from his grasp particularly when
he's in time pressure and he essentially
forces simplifications like he
understands very well of when to press
and how to not overpress and that served
him well in this match it really has and
right now the 995 is pinned ding at 11
seconds still plenty of time if you can
find the quick moves and Mommy I'm just
saying let's trade off some stuff and
okay actually this could be dangerous
for blocking to be very yeah that pawn
is a pretty much a long-term weakness
whereas the pawn on B3 is very safely
protected by the night if only blackened
a light squared Bishop to put on D5
unfortunately he doesn't and
ooh more weaknesses on the king side now
yeah four very good move carving out
squares
E4 now E5 is a weakness and this knight
from C2 could entrench itself on one of
those Central squares
this is an end game master at play here
Robert yeah you know he's exceptional
and E5 is defended so Knight B5 played
and is there Knight C3 so we trade
oh yeah still Knight C5 I think black is
fine but yeah Knight takes E5 Knight
takes E4 Knight D3
Bishop D Bishop E7
is it like this should be a drop I'm
gonna go Knight F4 Knight E2 but then
I'm not even threatening your whoa okay
what I takes G3
what was H5 H5 he pushed the wrong Pawn
okay Bishop completely mishandling this
and he's gonna lose on time if he's not
careful Bishop G5 I'm looking at the H
Pawn Donya so the bishop is the wrong
color just keep that in mind in case
white needs a sacrifice a knight for the
G Pawn to make it draw at some point
which is likely and white bee Pawn is
rushing up the board so fast
oh no another flag this is the third
time we've seen someone losing the clock
I I I told you at the start I've just I
I don't get it I mean you just you have
to force yourself to move and these
players know that and maybe it's okay
maybe it's a connection thing it could
be man oh man that is a lot I'm
wondering what's about to happen in the
bullet let me let me quickly check while
you talk about this game I'm looking to
see how many bullet games around has
played on chess.com because I'm yeah
it's not many it's uh you want to guess
how many bullet games he's playing I'm
gonna guess uh I'm gonna say
45 30.
okay that was close yeah that was and
that is not a lot uh that's not a lot so
I'm starting to get nervous for him
based on how he's handled the time
pressure he really has been just too
slow and he also just I think I'm seeing
the dreaded Red Bar
on his
connection let's check his camera oh
this camera is still alive
so it seems that he's gotten boot out of
the server and you can tell he's got two
minutes now and move four
yeah hopefully he gets that fixed soon
I'm sure the team will
work hard to get him back there but he's
uh
there we go there he is like he's back
phew
yeah that's always a relief when
well what's not a relief is that he's
now a minute down on move four and we
have another ragazen
no he is
um
sorry I said ding was involved with like
the ultimate that sportsmanship thing
when he and Magnus played right uh where
Magnus won a game
in one of the Champions Chester matches
and then he like gave away the second
game because he won by I don't know if
his disconnection or whatever it was so
uh thing Lauren has a unfortunate
history of being in some situations that
maybe the connection issues play A Part
yeah and maybe I I passed on my issues
to him because the the Bay Area had a
big big internet outage uh just this
past night so
I guess um
it transferred to ding side of the world
well right now he's even on the clock so
I don't know what just happened with
Mama jar because when I moved to seven
like was he just saying I shouldn't be
up on time that that's not how I want to
gain my lead on the clock but either way
we're back into a familiar position that
we saw that was very sport that was that
was a sportsman move right there by
shock he he did not he wasn't actually
thinking yeah he was sitting there to
give away back the time advantage that
was it was a nice gesture right there
and I was just referencing uh what
Magnus did and Shakura and Mama drop
proving himself to just be a good guy
right like that is this reminds me of
David Navara who is just a legendary
chess player but you know the in some
talking about where uh he like in a Time
scramble he like accidentally grazed a
piece and they felt bad about it so at
the end of the game he offered a draw in
a winning position against Grandmaster
moisenko and that was like you know
applauded uh across the world and it's
great to see players who are you know
they want to win the match but they also
want to win over the board and not
because of a disconnection or anything
so really nicely done my mama jar of
there I agree and that kind of stuff
just brings you to tears and I think
it's easy to be nice
um with your gestures and to you know
shake your opponent's hands and and
congratulate him on a good game when
you've won what's hard to do is
something that actually affects the
result of the game when push comes to
shove these kinds of gestures that
really uh alter potentially the result
of the game you know that I think really
shows the true colors of these players
and I think almost without exception
Robert all of the top players they're
fierce competitors they're Tigers
they're gladiators but they're also
great uh amazing uh you know gentlemen
and Sportsmen and and that just adds a
magic element to the game in my opinion
well some of them are at least some of
them some of them some of them yeah I
guess I was a little too generous there
but yeah let's say some of them well
well hopefully
um
no definitely not but he's a top player
so I was just waiting for you to install
my chest I'll do it to myself so here
wait did I just accidentally compliment
you by calling yeah you did so I I just
oh man I took it away don't worry but
here this end game where white has these
double pawns the uh potential good news
is the open B file maybe some pressure
but I could see white losing this game
like those a pawns are quite vulnerable
and King B5 is next maybe a shock I
regretting he's like wait actually ding
could you give me some of that time back
I changed my mind
I'm Bishop C6 here right like Bishop C6
Rook C1 check maybe he can be pushing
what were you saying about top player in
my name yet no I just don't blinking no
nothing yeah ding does not we might see
a repetition of moves here King E7 or
he's playing for it
he should no he can't lose his black
unless he blunders his Rook like I did
so he might as well play for one well
the thing is that if you take on C6 you
give black a fast Pawn so chakra are
insisting on trading on his own terms
as does ding he says let's trade Rooks
because nope
take King B6
wait a minute what if you
could you just like like
I I was thinking you could have like
King D6 to Rook D3 and just protected
the B7 point I want to keep my queen
side pawns from Black's perspective and
then have Mama jarg deal with uh his
double totally totally get what you're
saying now a six
takes in B6 I can't quite find the way
for white to force a drag goes H4 okay
the idea is that now okay these things
oh gosh this is looking nastier and
nastier for white this might just be
losing
so he's trying to just checking over B1
back and forth so King C7 King B8 Hydro
King a very nice and look at how weak
those pawns are he wants to gain one
more second here and then he'll can be
eight okay
he's trying to gain the time
King B8
there it is
close to a three-time repetition now can
white get away with A4 A4 Rook D5
a six and B6 maybe can I agree do that
just win one of your Pawns
hmm
then maybe Rook C4 okay goes Rook C4
immediately
what does he want
because Rook F4 F5 does not work out
black one's too clean pawns yeah if you
lose the second one Black's gonna have
connected passers and that basically
spells Doom this is lost like the only
way to defend the pawn is Rook C5 and
then I go Rook D3 Rook D5 or something
like that or A6 Rook B5 like
I I don't think you can
actually protect that pawn you could
also probably just like B6 right away
after Rook C5 and then
Venture slowly forward wait can you try
H5 G5 Rook takes G5 no no I'm crazy
h6358
but I feel like he's going for it but
the idea is a really good one to keep in
mind but it just doesn't work out for
white in the moment yeah he's going for
eight shape that's a creative way to win
the pawn but it's not going to be fast
enough I think wait a minute G4 was that
necessary Robert I don't think so he's
doing B5 B4 and so on but she just wants
to play Rook H like Rook hh6 black will
play Rook H5 so The Rook he's doing a
good job on the fifth rank but now rook
h8 and what white is going to do is use
that h-man as a decoy and try to win at
least one of Black's passers on the
queen side I think chakra might be
saving this
oh H7
H7 King F7
takes thinking six six and Rook H5 is
going to depend upon
don't like the F2 Pawn the pawn G4 is so
good for black E4 okay now
to Rooks
rookie five and then King F5 Maybe
if I you want to give the F7 Pawn
no honestly I've wondered it I
appreciate your honesty I blundered so
many times today so I got you uh I like
this though Rook bias for that way you
can go Rook G8 at some point but Rook G8
he's like take my G Pawn then my b-pawn
nobody but also the question what if
white just does nothing here in two
seconds Bobby Darin has to make a move
with B6
black is I think going to give up the F7
Pawn at one point he's just gonna go
here go for it yeah I know he's winning
oh whoa
is he just repeating moves or something
no way you have to try King C6 there is
no risk there unbelievable okay we
talked about Mama Jara being a nice guy
because he gave the time back dingley
Wren was too nice there to make it right
now King C6 give up F7 push the beep on
memory with two seconds that's
essentially indefensible no and it's one
of those moments say it a lot where it's
Pawn quality versus quantity yeah Black
start up a pawn but who cares if the
material equalizes if that B Pawn can
roam free so that was a mischance for
ding Loren and I think he'll regret that
because that would have set give more
Separation on the scoreboard and now Mom
and Jerry should feel much more
confident yeah I mean that's one of
those things where you know you mount
the 10 minute drive you know you convert
some four downs and then you know you
kick a field goal rather than going for
the fourth and one it's like you gotta
gotta press that gas pedal down now
obviously ding knows best he's up a
point on the other hand
you know maybe he was worried about
something and I think he's put he's
putting faith in the bullet
which um I'm so excited for the bullet
because it's a complete toss-up I wonder
what's gonna happen
yeah I don't know very excited for the
bullet the players but I am as well
and all right by the way they're excited
for the bullet this just looks like
another Pleasant Knight D2 going to C4
this looks like another Pleasant
Advantage for dingly red yeah and if you
go B5 then you weaken the C5 Square so
there's just no winning here with black
you're gonna weaken one square one way
or another
now ding just loves these positions he's
so good at getting them he's very
consistently getting these types of
positions with the white pieces whether
it's in a Catalan and a rogozin and a
queen's gamut accepted shock is just not
quite able to get his type of positions
I think what I like best about being
lyron's play is he makes it seem so
effortless like every time I watch him
out of the opening it's like wow how do
I get that advantage and right it's not
just because people are making mistakes
against him it's because he just under
has to deep understanding and he's so
calm with his moves and it is insanely
impressive so right now is a critical
moment I think because the B6 Pawn is a
little soft so if you can dislodge that
Bishop from C5 and A3 B4 maybe even play
B4 right away and just like give up your
B Pawn for the enemy be upon but I feel
like Mom Jarvis
he's found his way through the opening
struggle
right and in terms of the the notion of
making things look easy right it's a
cliche in a lot of sports including in
chess what constitutes how what does it
mean for somebody to make something look
easy well I think in chess it means
somebody who makes seemingly simple
moves doesn't do anything extraordinary
doesn't sacrifice any Queens
uh and yet you know crushes strong
players regularly and and quickly and
ignorant is doing exactly that here but
as you said where that comes from is a
very very deep understanding of
positional ideas and let's Rook A7 yeah
look what he just did he kind of lulled
us into the sense of I'm just gonna play
communicate deep positional ideas and
Bam he goes for a tactical shot with B4
because B6 is hanging so the very least
you can put make the material equal
again but Rook A7 how does blocking
respond to Rook A7 he's done for Knights
xp6 which is not a draw for because
black is still black still has to be
very careful that Knight on F6 is flimsy
Rook C7 is threatened but what if Knight
D5
does white actually have anything there
or has ding
wait a second here I'm actually very
surprised you didn't play Rook A7
oh no I thought Bishop takes D5 Rook C7
Rook D7 there's some trick with Bishop
yeah
yeah it is really weird because Rook A7
just looked relatively risk-free
and now it looks even
takes takes and uh
so we're seeing all this
I'll go for Bishop F6 check after Rook
D7 and hope the King goes the back rank
against mated but they won't and another
opportunity which I wouldn't say it was
a blown opportunity I wouldn't say that
Ding was winning
but that was a phenomenal opening that
didn't really materialize into anything
kind of strange question Dania but is
there any chance that black gets in some
trouble here because the king is stuck
on f8 like I play F3 Heroes white oh
there's another okay one check anyway
okay I thought Rook A1 Bishop E1 is made
but no A1 is defended
so he plays H4
and is there is there opportunity here
for white just to press on with a free
hand like if you go G4 next for white
black is not taking on G4 that's how you
lose this game
right allowing white to create a passer
with H5 yeah shocker are trying to
dislodge that Rook from the seventh rank
but the key is to dislodge the Bishop
from F6 so maybe you go Bishop d8 here
yeah the bishop A5 was a really good
move and we've seen dingley Wren played
Bishop d8 in that other position a
couple times Bishop dates where it's at
I think there might be a draw for here
that probably accompanied this move
or maybe not maybe white is still
playing it for a win or if I'm mama
jarov maybe I plan just to waste match
clock to get to the bullet
yeah that's an interesting strategy
because you're losing the match but if
you put faith in your bullet skills
Dania sorry to interrupt you no please
do there's some potential for white to
win this game right be careful like
black is very passive and all those
pollens are in light squares between the
white Bishop can attack them and ding is
trying to get his King to D6 King E7 was
an important move now do you take on F6
or do you play Bishop D3 and try to
induce F5
I
okay
how does Muhammad yarov set up his
defense
well it's a light Square bishop and H is
a dark Square so I think there's no
winning chances yeah
and also you're not even going to win
any pawns yeah I mean even E5 should be
a draw
and he plays it also sorry I didn't mean
to cut you off before I just thought no
no suddenly it could get exciting but
um what would you say though if you were
Mama jarv's coach or dingley Ren's coach
uh but what would you say about the
possibility of having the bullet would
you like play these positions out or is
that a weird mindset to have when you
know regular game of chess you just
offer a draw no not at all I think you
need to optimize your chances and
I don't think even mamijaro knows
exactly what ding Loren's bullet skill
is but given ding's relative lack of
experience and Miami has played a lot of
bullet recently he started to stream
I've seen him play a lot of bullet
matches I think he's probably going to
be more experienced and more confident
there's nothing wrong with bleeding out
as much clock as you can and I think
that's exactly what he's doing because
King takes H5 is an immediate draw and
you can see that he's waiting
as much as possible and now he's going
to take on F3
and he's gonna bleed as much clock as
possible before doing that he answered
the question for us so how nice but what
I will say is yesterday's match which
you had the call for when I was watching
before the match JKD was the huge
favorite come bull at time and yet Anish
Geary took him by storm like just beat
him and uh that that was impressive and
surprising to even a niche right so
you're correct I think that mom and
daughter was the favorite but you should
not underestimate dingley run the guy is
27.99 in classical chess for a reason
and a great Blitz player we should add
that on top and and wrap it in a whole
time with trolls you know Magnus Carlson
didn't lose a tiebreaker until he lost
to dingley Ren in that's right tie
breaks
and what's more is that if he manages to
get these types of positions with white
then defending like a nasty Catalan or a
bad you know Queen's Gambit accepted end
game in a bullet game is one of the
nastiest situations you can be in I mean
it's almost impossible so
yeah no I'm absolutely not not burying
him
and it's you know I can I can see this
going in any direction
although the way the trajectory of the
games that we've seen thus far where
they start very calmly and then explode
I think in bullet that's favorable for
the more tactical players because
um you know skin squeeze precisely it's
hard to make that work in bullet but
blundering a tactic happens all the time
so I I I'm that Dynamic the difference
in style will be interesting as well and
here by the way manager's position I
sort of like the look of it with H4 oh
my oh gosh that is spicy right there and
he didn't even think about taking that
an item allowing the opening of the H
file of the a file rather he he believed
him and then he should believe him but I
would also believe Dean Lauren the guy
doesn't just set up pieces for no reason
they're not speculative sacrifices yeah
when he sacrifices it's for a very very
good reason and queen F6 now hitting
after all of a sudden Bishop F5 is
coming in and white skin might be the
one caught on the crosshairs
yeah if your move is Queen to B1 after
Knight to B4 you know you're in some
trouble
maybe this is the time to take the night
although I don't think so because after
a b the queen can swing to C6 I mean if
you are going 94. the queen she's wait
Queen
C6 looks juicy
that basically forces either the Knight
back to C3 or forces Bishop C3
but in response to Bishop C3 I can play
something like Bishop E6 and set up
Knight A2 check this is looking terrible
yeah there's that is also F5 for black
which looks a bit risky but it kicks the
Knight out of the center yeah I like a
five
uh Bishop E6 also looks great though
the one thing on Bishop E6 is there
could be like a knight F6 no well what
about Bishop B5
Queen takes B5 something like this is
what you're talking about Knight F6
obviously it doesn't work for whatever
reason but Bishop E6 played
now wait a minute what if you start with
nah none of that works because black is
982 track is an intermezzo
but how scary is Knight A2
depends on what white does I guess it is
pretty scary Rook g1982 King D2
I mean
and Rook bd8 you want to go Bishop D4
King E1 one of those probably Bishop D4
I can I can get behind that I can see
what you're saying
because I think C3 yeah it takes H7 mate
all of a sudden two looks like White's
pieces are all kind of in the doldrums
but all it takes is one little pin to
create the main thread mommy Dr of
contemplating that I like the I like the
look of Rook G1 yeah after Rook G1
honestly it would be 10 just like King
h8 but then there's Knight G5 and you're
threatening the main on H7 anyway so
right King is in a little bit of danger
not going to be checkmated for sure not
but there is some danger that you have
to figure out Never Say Never and you're
right you can't entirely escape the
pressure after rook q1 and Mama you are
deciding to take that night maybe he
wants Bishop B5 and Knight F6 that idea
we talked about
okay so he's going for it
okay I think I understand the problem is
it's gonna be there's gonna be a bishop
G7 in there at some point
and then after
oh my gosh no Donna the problem is the
queen is trapped on B1 this is
unbelievable so here here here yes Rook
G1 Bishop G7 Bishop takes seven six and
then Bishop F5
oh my God Rook takes G7 King f8 E4 and
this queen C6 Queen C6 picking off the
bishop and this is all happening Bishop
F6 has been placed will he see the
cold-blooded Bishop F5 with two ideas
not fearing Rook takes G7 I completely
understand like that is what I wanted to
go for too when I was looking at this
position from the white side but then
you get to the position and now it's
easy enough for ding to figure out I
feel like where you see that yeah what
are you gonna do the G7 Bishop's under
attack you could probably even just like
Bishop B3 which is like the calmest move
and then after Rook 17 f8 and okay thing
is chilling I said it and he does it but
the queen C6 check is such a big threat
but if she ate various options whoa now
Mama Dr of
I think he forgot that there's a king on
C1 because if there wasn't a king on C1
he would go Rook q1 Rook G8 and that
typical idea with a queen getting to G1
but the queen can't jump over the king
that is that would have been first he's
so sick if that I know
for a second yeah yeah I can D2 let's
just make a random move and that Rook G8
Queen join of course this would have
been continuous we just haven't made
actually seeing this and the GM game is
so rare it's over
wow that that you actually think it was
that he forgot his kings in the way or
he just was a lot like lost well I'm
also looking at his facial expression I
feel like there was a little
twinge of annoyance there I mean it
couldn't have been anything else because
Queen takes H7 obviously loses to a
million different things
he he did ensure that this is the last
game though of the three plus one
yep Queen C6 by the way I think is the
cleanest and then Queen takes F6 cuts
the leg off legs off from the attack
yeah when he plays it
as you lose on time or resign either way
not only is this game over the three
plus one time Patrol is done with it's
ten to eight in ding's favorite that's a
two-game lead we don't know his bullet
skills he only played a couple matches
uh a bullet so not enough to really
judge him off of and Dania
I feel like Mama jarov even though he
just lost that last game he's got a lot
of fight in him right now I I sense that
hunger
yeah he's got I'm looking for a
particular word that I'm forgetting it's
not Verve
um it's not grit although he's got those
things as well I'm going to remember
that word and share it on the other side
of the break but he's got that Spirit uh
he's got the gumption going and one just
gets the sense that he's got a few more
things to say but Daniel Iran has been
as solid as a rock he's had great time
management and those things bowed really
well for him in the bullet section I
can't wait for the last 30 minutes of
this match nor can I but everyone must
wait because we're gonna take a short
break but when returned it will be the
bullet portion of this STC match between
chakra mom jarov and dingly red
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess.com's new game review is packed
with exciting new features and major
updates play a game and check out this
whole new experience combining key
moments brilliant moves like the one you
see on screen in front of you by Amman
Hamilton great moves explanations from
the coach and more game review is
available to premium members now and
will be available to all members soon
and Dania we've seen many brilliant
moves thus far we for sure will see a
good number of blunders as we get into
the bullet portion of this matchup
between dingley Grand and Shop there are
Mom and jarov I'm pretty stoked like
normally bullet is it's wild it's
enjoyable for an entertainment
perspective but I'm just like I'm loving
the Clash of styles between these two
and I feel like we're just gonna get
more of it in the bullet
yeah I'm getting major like Unstoppable
Force versus immovable objects kind of
Vibes and that's always great it's
always great to see as you said The
Clash of styles but speaking of
thinking of bad stuff happening this is
the worst moment to disconnect
15 seconds at the start of the game
but good to see that he's back and we
have a Queen's Gambit accepted to start
to build a disaster averted or so it
seems yeah and with the one second
increment it's not the end of the world
it really isn't
um but here we've seen this before quick
moves being played because they're gonna
get past five Queens he's made up some
time he's back to 50 seconds and they've
already had this once it's pretty good
news for Bing because this position well
not now but if Queen D6 the resulting
queenless position is relatively easy to
play this is more complicated with the
Queen's on the board and perhaps you
know the fact that chakra is resisting
the queen trade
um maybe he is factoring things time
situation into account A6 to stop Knight
B5 coordinating his pieces it looks like
White's better but literally Anything
could happen in a position like this
it's unbalanced enough you have a knight
C2 How Are You Gonna Save that maybe not
yeah Knight C2 you'd have had to go
rotate taking playing slow B3 and now
he's doubling Rooks on the D file and
it's because the A2 Pawn was loose over
there so if he had played uh you know
rookie two Rook D1 first he would have
lost upon A2 and said he makes sure
that's defended look at the dark squares
domination number three Bishop G5 Rook
C1 night before shockery are trying to
do what he can to connect these Pawns
maybe bishop E5 and queen F6 yeah looks
like that seems pretty nice okay for
some reason oh this is way too passive
Knight takes A2
oh yeah that would have been so strong
because B3 would have found there as
well
opportunities being missed here by both
sides not the first time we've seen an
a7a2 Pawn just loose and not captured so
uh this still looks good to my eyes for
white uh the kingside initiative looks
promising and B4 at some point I think
should be played
and doing driving a spawned all the way
up to H6 that pawn is going to be there
even after the apocalypse because the
bishop on F4 is going to defend it
forever it's essentially unattackable
and now he tries to break into Black's
Pawn chain with B4 I'm a jar of down on
down on the clock here despite the uh
disconnection at the start The Rook on
E6 you know it's going up to E5 now but
just Bishop got four and C5 is falling
no G4 is possible is the work trapped it
is Rook H 13 G2 you have to go Rook H4
but then Bishop G5 yeah then King G2
after it his track is lost that so it's
to be essentially over being around
spots 15 seconds and then just goes and
plays a great game yeah maybe he should
do that every game oh and maybe that was
a deliberately choreographed
disconnection you can't even take on F4
no background mate would have been a
thing Rook A1 now okay Rook CH for this
check and check
Network
F4 still one needs to be accurate
Rook A1 never gonna be played this is
even better because H7 can be played
as the great Robert Hess says it's all
about the quality of the past one of me
yes having two Rooks though it does help
just a little bit
oh that's a nice move
cheeky
still not quite able and Rook H2 is
coming that's gonna end the game at last
and now the lead up to three dang wins
the first bullet game and pretty
convincingly so I must add although
Shakura did have that brief opportunity
to capture on A2
yeah I agree it's convincing like there
was one single move where Mom and jar
had a chance to uh really just win a
pawn and get the upper hand but other
than that it felt like didn't control
the game from start to finish so it's
bullet those mistakes happen as you know
you play a lot of bullet you're really
good at it
um I just make the mistakes I don't
actually redeem myself after them
but no I I do a little bit of it wait
isn't there yeah
okay this is again they get one of these
structures that they've had so many
times in the ragazen and the Queen's
Gambit accepted
it feels like white is just a tiny bit
better due to the sort of more active
pieces but black is just so solid here
now he's completely neutralized whites
if anything I would quite possibly
prefer black at this point I would
definitely but Bishop C7 at some point
you can reroute yeah if you'd like to
and double on the D file get control of
that file
A6 Bishop B5 could be tossed in yeah
that Knight is doing nothing and it's
doing even less there's an idea of going
H5 H4 here it comes X play is just the
position essentially plays itself Bishop
C2 is nice preparing 94 against stage
four
I do like that 94 now you need to get
the Knight into the game so nothing on
G3 and you can just trade Rooks you have
the Bishops I I probably wouldn't
okay I would say I wouldn't trade all
the Rooks fire black because it feels
like it removes winning chances but then
I realize what do you need to win for
you just need to not lose if you're
dignity yeah playing the match between
it's coming to C3
ding is a little bit low on the clock
but he's got over half of his time left
that should be enough
ooh risky move very risky I love it sure
about that at four is coming and E3 is
going to be lost love the move F5 in
Quincy look at that two queens E3 is
still a problem E3 is a huge problem
Knight Duo E4 okay now black has great
winning chances in this end game maybe
you can even take on F2 that's what I
was wondering like Bishop D4 and this
would be plays is a good move but I was
wondering if you use take on F2 King G5
King F4 but why give up your Bishop pair
no rush for anyone that is the typical
plan and White's position is essentially
on the bridge of collapse this has also
gotten a lot of time off the match clock
if chakra loses this game that brings
him on the cusp of disaster
still enough time to bounce back here
but oh for sure and he's not lost yet
this actually still might be a draw ding
fixes all of white spawns on the light
squares but can he access them with his
Bishop I'm afraid the answer is no no
it's one of these positions down there
with a G6 Pawn needs to be on G3 so you
have a sacrifice on H3 available with
Pawn back there there's is locked up
it's just a draw I'm not so sure wait a
second
what if you try to go
no no never mind I was gonna say
something insane you want to go like get
your Bishop in somehow
you know I I know people are laughing
but sometimes you can actually do that
you know Bishop A2 and you can zoos on
your way in but not here
yeah there are also times where you're
playing with like Bishop B3 giving up
your Bishop for free and the King dashes
to F2 oh my God that would have been
pretty interesting actually I was
actually trying to calculate it but I
was like no this is probably the bishop
reroutes to like G4 and again they get
this opening
yep I don't know
if I would repeat this if I were Shaq to
be honest
I I'm curious like look this up later
and figure out what the deal is what the
history of this opening is because they
played it a lot and I don't have that
much familiarity in the McDonald defense
of the Queen's Gambit accepted yeah but
I just feel like this is very thankless
I mean when you have this many
weaknesses along one particular color
it's just so hard to handle this
particularly in bullet the queen keeps
dropping back to chew through there's
this h4h5 idea of the ding has essayed
many oh Knight C3 look at that move
using the pin getting the night item to
D5 or to B5 I think this is looking
terribly you've been polite Dania this
has just been a bad opening for Mom
giraffe like even if objectively it's
okay the way it's gone has been so easy
it might be for hitting cset right E5
clever but it's not going to work like
64.96 don't try it this is a tilt move
and it's going to lose the game very
quickly
that was a very very bad game and I'm
shocked that he repeated this line
you just
easy to play at this point
yeah ding is not gonna let this one go
Knight H6 you can just go Rook C1 if he
wants look at look at these ducks oh
look at these squares oh Knight G4 swiss
cheese going on here Queen uh maybe
Queen H6 King G8
that's what's happening in 93 I think is
I usually play met F2 but I'd rather
than Knight E3 yeah
and it's only a question of time until
white gets this bishop onto the long
diagonal
he's holding on he's doing what he can
but he really is like this isn't the
game isn't over yet no but but it is
um
Bishop B3 Bishop D4 no Bishop E3 Queen
f8
oh look at you very tricky Queen if I
played he could even take on f8 and take
on C7 but then the game definitely isn't
over okay I amend my I amend my opinion
of this did he really just like Rook D
how did he get out of that Bishop Q5
there's Rift takes D2 but Rook d8 felt
he could have like kept repeating and
save his Rook d8 he's going for the win
no maybe you're just down upon that I
know I'm kidding I know it's just it
just seems surprising another game that
takes a lot of time off the matchbox
still 20 minutes left plenty of time
even if he loses this game but Ahmad and
I were discussing this yesterday some of
these players do have a propensity for
you know repeating bad lines maybe
there's a little bit of Pride involved
maybe more than a little bit but it's
costume here I I honestly think what it
is is they have studied these openings
so in depth and it may be about Pride
but it's also like they know that it's a
decent opening yeah but when you're
playing Blitz and bullet you don't have
time to remember what is good is a
decent opening right or a certain point
you're like oh well in all my analysis
it says white is only slightly better
but slightly oh king of goodbye and the
king is blown oh Bishop C8 shock finding
every last resource the problem is that
the Rook is going to vacuum up these
last two Pawns
right
or not all you need is one pawn and it's
rushing forward to promotion
and here comes E6
and so on okay
oh my god king D6 he should have played
what should he have played Rook F5 first
no you have a king E7
that wasn't easy to see now this is
yeah rookie six it's a drawing whoa why
does it be well rookie five
okay I just be careful yeah I think G4
King G4
rookie six this is so close to being
lost for white and now ding has to count
as lucky stars and shock proves me wrong
he saves a draw unfortunately he's still
down by three points he needs to win
games and he needs to start with this
one time is ticking
and we have another ragazen this time he
goes Queen A4 check
oh gosh I mean I'm getting nervous for
the players here and A3 taking with the
B4 so E5 striking the center we had this
once before that was the game where dick
played Knight before Oh yeah this is
like happened very recently but now Rook
G1 early Rook G1 I think there's a
better way to play this because if
there's a king on G8 a semi-open file
you want to use that to your advantage
ding
not varying his approach to the position
and I don't believe he should this looks
still very very promising for black but
hard to play on a bullet game yeah I I
don't like this Choice gen Queen C6
check but this time with the Rook
already on G1 white will be threatening
Knight F6 sooner that's right so Bishop
C3 oh wait I think White's been about to
win and not just sooner but this might
be unstoppable and as you pointed out
Robert Knight G5 in certain positions
can also be very strong
but neither how do you stop Knight F6
rookie six but then Rook comes to d8
Knight F6 so he's a trade Queen Knight
F6 Queen F6 Bishop six Bishop takes B1
but the ensuing position is clearly good
for white however with the queen trade
Black's feeling a little bit more safe
but one minute left on his clock for Mom
and giraffe
unbelievable and Rook G1 was a
phenomenally astute decision Rook is
coming to D7
this dark squared Bishop coming alive as
well
this he has to convert this absolutely
hasta has to has to convert this okay
Bishop the bishop pair is so strong here
Rook D7 is about to happen
right about now yeah I guess ding wants
for E7
right exactly that's the right sound to
make then Rook gg1 I mean F4 is looking
pretty nice as well just
you can play F5
Rook d8
wait a second I understand that shock is
attacking but
he's not coming anywhere close to mating
black skin well it's not enough pieces
for that if you've gone H4 H5 maybe he
would have made it him but he won H3
instead I think he's still flirting with
ideas of made maybe he wants F4 E4 E5
you just put e45 immediately because the
background Checkmate he should have done
that faster because now a three four
black and go rookie eight okay ding not
trying to stop him from going E5 yeah
the A5 Palm is also loose and
yeah weird weird decisions here by by
shock to be honest yeah he won rookie
four maybe still should be 27 King E6
oh d8 Rook d8 it's the only open file
for white Rook C1 I guess
okay that is not a good sign no it's not
in fact this could turn around black
could win his game look at those pawns
squares
Rook takes H5 and white gets the passer
in fact yeah Rook H5 convert Q4 check
just King F3 and
free okay three keep checking keep
bleeding time off the clock this is
obviously not over that King on E6 is
incredibly powerful but white is
threatening rook h8 and rookie a rook h
a and then yeah H5 H6 h76 is also an
idea rookie 8 and E6 I think is great
because King E7 rookie seven check and
others you say E6 bands his gamut's Cam
and that's gonna be Mahmoud yara's first
one in the bullet and a big one it comes
exactly at the right time
and we've got right around half of the
bullet portion still remaining yeah he
is plenty of time to mount oh yeah
that's the scary thing you get into this
you start feeling confident if you're
doing the random the next thing you know
you lose a game like that we're all that
moment is just one move from the opening
and it changed the entire Dynamic of the
game
God my heart is beating this is exciting
and we have another Blumenfeld I think
Mama Yara was smelling blood
he senses that if he wins one more gets
that lead down to one he has plenty of
time and again we have this E4 d45 and
okay I'm gonna sound like a broken
record here Robert but another opening
that I don't think Mama Dr should be
repeating I'm with you the he did change
you an A6 early in this game rather than
uh Knight D7 or whatever it was so he's
made some slight adjustments but here
Knight G5 and ig5 fg5
that's like oh wait Bishop G5 that's a
weird move Queen A5 check I guess he
wants to drop the bishop back to D2
right so Queen D5 hitting the knight in
the center it's a nice move Bishop D3
there'd be C4 well Bishop G5 is bad
because it Hogs the G5 score away from
the knights which actually need it that
Bishop on G5 is neither here nor there
and it also leaves the other Bishop a
bit loose so
F4 okay he wants a bishop on C4 and that
becomes very close to trapping the queen
oh gosh wait a second
between F5 though
five night G yeah I was thinking that
too G6 maybe ding should just Castle
after Queen F5
uh just leave the 994 and go for
checkmate
so wait so where's the follow-up here
like Castle rookie one a6b5 is
potentially a threat so he deals with
that first at Bishop A6
then maybe Castle anyway
positionally white is just dominating
right the Knight will come into C4 uh
it's it's a problem for black F5 is also
a nasty idea potentially just blasting
everything open right now is good for
sure we need to ding playing it a little
bit more passively
but 10 seconds for Shaq I mean
this is virtually unplayable
okay so Bishop E7 Queen E7 still still
fighting here it comes just Castle
then F6 maybe uh
I guess you can take on you okay oh my
goodness I bought them apples using that
E6 spawn as an umbrella so creative that
shock has shown time and time again he
just doesn't die in these positions no
if he turned this one around Robert
that's a huge turning point right there
dang is not playing this too confidently
slow move and the E6 Pawn right now is
on the verge of falling foreign
look at the speed here all of a sudden
he's trying the afterburner's on
rookie two I like it be sure to give
three wait a minute
one's winning on the
honest oh my goodness he still has a
past Pawn though it's like in 195 is
coming to C3
is coming wow and he pre-moved it no
that's just good Playboy that's a draw
wait a minute good play Knight B6 is a
great move right nice it's so smart
that's silly he's dragging the king away
he rewards the king off and then he's
gonna drive his King in
yeah this should be a draw with Josh is
winning in one move there Robert by
taking the Knight he did everything
it could flow 11 minutes left he has to
find a way to save this can he take on
before I was wearing the same thing
he doesn't and now I feel like he's
gonna lose this
it's so excuse me
five was a drop
on H5 put the King on G6 and play H6 oh
he plays six oh this is nice taking take
on G5 you made a draw okay and now you
just big big big save right there that
keeps him in the match still plenty of
time but he needs two more points yeah
but and which remind everybody you just
need to start the final game before that
last second very very important
whoo my goodness so now moment of the
white piece is he's going back to this
game bragosan that we've seen why not
time again that Rook G1 was devastating
for black ding confident in his
preparation let's see what he comes up
with
okay H6 I think that's a new move yeah
that was not playing he's previously
played E5 ripping open the center here
he keeps the center relatively close
mommy there are still castling long I
think he's gonna go Rook q1 to G4
although DC4 B5 B4 is happening very
quickly you kind of wish that Paul was
an A2 rather than A3 he doesn't care he
says I'll keep that C4 Pawn as an
umbrella I am shoving G5 right through
and I'm going for checkmate I love this
idea for mommy jar of G5 is basically
Unstoppable yeah great decision by him
and Knight D5 G5 just push it G5 and G6
oh yeah keep that pong going G6 oh gosh
and then Bishop takes C4 looks very
strong he decides to delay that but now
fantastic shape G6 for black could have
at least made it harder for white to
break through over there now G6 will
sacrifice for sure B4 is also not a move
because the Knight on C6 is saying so
black might have to waste the tempo on
something like Bishop B7 yes but then
even 94 Knight C5 just positionally
invading those weak squares on the queen
side
check
he wants this see to me so the Palm will
go but whoa Knight G5 that might have
been a mouse slip
I mean it must be right
okay but now my major still has to be
careful rookie won
he cannot let this opportunity slip but
how does he put the finishing touches on
this game as ding tries to whip up
Connor Bland the Queen's side he'll go
I'll have to like Queen he's too slow it
feels like Knight c495. you have a block
of someone getting so much play against
White's King yeah but now Rook takes H5
is a huge threat okay 93 Knight F2
yeah now you do not have two works oh
Knight takes C3
I'm at jar of trying to hide away with
his king queen A2 check there will be
Knight C2 while he actually is
succeeding Rook takes H5
The Rook H5 Queen
you just do it and close your eyes and
prayed oh you don't have you don't have
a move for white right now
bringing the Rook up is not sweating not
good for black but oh my goodness white
didn't have a breakthrough like Bishop
G8 check right I see what you're saying
wait a second this is still not over
Knight H3 is a very awkward move wait
why did he go Knight H3 to protect the
F2 Pawn okay I guess
okay now you got 30 seconds he can slow
down King C1 maybe just tuck the king
away temporarily or Knight c495 I really
like that C6 is here six that's
definitely a mouse if you meant to play
C5 oh my God that's such a critical
Mouse slip because now you know what
game Rook takes C5 mommy drives just
says I'm taking that pawn but Bishop D5
locks The Rook in it can't get back to
H5 but Knight G4 okay he's not on G5
because the Queen's on G2 either King
can get mated here
Knight G5 Knight F7 is 144. oh my God
that threatens Rook B1 so Rook defense
what what what was that oh he wants
Bishop takes C5 no Bishop B3 what is he
doing Knight G5 attacking the Queen
White should be winning here where was
that Rook see it whoa Bishop what is
that oh he's down he just gave away his
Rook he just had a meltdown right there
oh my goodness how many swings did we
just see in that game and Mama drift has
shrunk the lead to one with seven and a
half minutes remaining that was crazy
what what do you think what did we just
see did he just not realize Knight D3
blocked the queen or that his other Rook
was already on the B5 what I think he
didn't realize that 93 severed the
connection between the queen and the D1
square but even after he sacrificed the
Rogue I felt like there were more
chances and he just he had a bad free
move there in any case what an insane
game and Shakura comes away with it that
was a massive win and now with the black
pieces we have a catalane I like that
choice by ding Robert he's got to
stabilized he's got to calm down he's
got to play a good solid game even if he
doesn't win if you can make a draw here
uh you know just keep that point lead oh
my goodness
wow we've seen some good play from dingo
from the white so these positions are
right now Mom and jar of he is ready for
all sorts of battles and queen takes C4
E5 we've seen positions just like this
earlier today and well this I think this
person's seen this move where it's cool
so your big two Bishop's Advantage isn't
so much of an advantage when your Bishop
on D6 is just serving the purpose of
Defending C7 E5
that's right and white is a very
clear-cut idea Knight c394 as I was
indicating into Mahmoud Yara of sensing
the danger he goes Knight D4 dink
doesn't accept that pawn sacrifice
and if you take the pawn on D4 you do
open up some diagonals for blankets
you're not going to take the pawn I'm
going to make you take it E4 he's gonna
take it on his own terms and B2 is
hanging in something it is rookie eights
coming to hit the E4 Pawn so white can
go up upon right now but there are going
to be some repercussions of it opening
the position up maybe maybe you want to
go Rook a B1 it looks ugly but yeah
something like that but now rookie yay
and I thought that the D2 score should
have been reserved for White's knife oh
B5 distraction
before oh my goodness this should be
four uh oh you lose an exchange now
white has obvious compensation in the
form of that pawn Phalanx but how do you
how do you actually avoid your position
from collabsum you've got 20 seconds
maybe this might be another loss Knight
D4 you know giving up the change but
you're setting raid and the Knight comes
in C6 attacks the B5 Pawn as well the
Knight C6 now nerves of Steel there my
big yard placing A6 to improve its
position now getting his rook in Knight
C6 there's Queen 66 don't blunder that
way to Route 65 over D5 was actually
pretty nice C5 also a nice move E5 Queen
B6
okay with this game
Knight C6 is a blunder this is a knight
C2 C4 is possible but maybe you
shouldn't rush with that
big moment here he played zero Queen D4
oh no you don't want trade Queens
move that Queen back where Queen oh
you just 53 D6 look at that incredible
oh D6 there would have been Rook to 66.
this is really dangerous for white for
black I think just losing Bishop C6 easy
play potentially F5 E6 but maybe not
immediately you know what it looks like
honestly your play game Connect Four
you've already won so you might as well
connect five look at the pawn just right
shoot a D6 incredible and B4 let me
drive trying to complicated 10 seconds
per day it's not over yet oh the E6
maybe that was premature no wait a
second no the pawn Knight takes in D7
3 though that creates potential for
discovery that Pawn's gonna be
restrained by the king so D7 King E7
there's King D4 67
Bishop takes D7 that was a very accurate
move there by ding
King G1
not over yet C3
um Bishop five coming after C6 C1 was
such a nice move
dim is there is four I think you resign
I think you resigned with your mom and
Jarvis I think you make a couple more
moves it's not quite over yet maybe you
win that pawn on H2
yeah A2
OH Close Rook B2 Maybe
oh man I would I would continue playing
I would take a risk Rook takes H2 he's
dropped a pawn that's true he might not
lose this game in fact she five three
and a half minutes remaining if he loses
this game there might not be enough time
for two more that's what I'm I'm nervous
about now he's gonna resign
oh my God
he's paralyzed the bishop it's just a
draw just don't draw don't play like G5
and take plenty of time here plenty of
time here yes just keep keep the pin
going just just yeah okay three What A
Catch right there H5 okay ding wants to
bleed off as much clock as possible
although it's not gonna be enough for
him to bleed off the entire clock he's
got three minutes left there's no way he
cuts off three minutes off the match and
I think he's just gonna repeat
wow what a saved by Mama jar of here
just using the pin and I mean for ding
D1 I don't think it really it matters
that much because like whether he draws
now or in in a minute from now there's
still gonna be enough time for one more
game I mean he's not milking two and a
half more minutes here two minutes 50
seconds
the right mindset and into draw so we
have two minutes 45 seconds just about
and this if the game goes this it could
be the last game but if you know they
win early or it's a quick draw they're
still moving again one more game after
that wow buckle your seat belts a soccer
yard he's had the white pieces he's done
so well and an opening change by ding in
this critical game he goes for the
Taurus uh for the semitars which is a
very very solid opening a lot of traits
I love this Choice Robert by ding but
white gets that strong Pawn Center this
could turn tactical with a palm break in
the center black is not careful yeah
there are plenty of times where white
strikes with move D5 and you know it's
coming but you still can't stop it and
and so Rook D1 I believe should be
played here you can play H4 that's often
played by white because H3 is a little
calmer approach F6 and queen F4 is often
played here to defend the E4 Pawn right
this is a theoretically topical line
it's played a lot in classical chess and
it's a great choice I think by ding
trying to douse the Flames of ramadar's
initiative and I would have played Queen
C7 but maybe that's because I don't
really know the in how the ensuing
endgame goes but trading Queen sounds
like a good thing to me when my opponent
needs to win that's exactly right and
both sides playing really really fast
doing taking the first serious think and
he's got the time for it
deciding I think where to put a screen
Queen F6 or maybe Knight back to F6 yeah
lots of tempting options Queen F6
including like 95 Rook F3 that you had
to look out for so
hear things getting a little bit loosier
Equinox four Rook G3 ideas D5 available
at some point I absolutely think it is
and I think it might be available here
yeah yeah no I don't think you could
take twice and even but it can it takes
forever to calculate
that's exactly right and is there Queen
D6 is such a nice stabilizing move
creating a pin against White's Queen
okay nice move rookie seven potentially
Rook ce7 I like that move a lot Rook E7
is a great move he plays it A7
I guess white should just move the
Knight back he goes
75. oh was there Knight F7 rookie six oh
my goodness
all sorts of tactics available in these
positions and Knight takes F7 is still
on the cards if black takes on D5 didn't
go King f8 man oh my God
G6 you gotta go back this is gonna be
the last game Bobby darf has to win it
you can do it or maybe it's Ace no A7 a
loud draw by like fours like rookie five
I would go F4
F4 looks good it's defend the night he
goes E4 trying to carve out space there
on the queen side A6 dig not giving an
inch
wow
F4 feels like the move back to A2 that
doesn't seem to be seems to be a
panicking move and ding just copies him
and says show me what you got Shaq wait
Bishop d55 now oh oh it's collapsing it
is collapsed this should be one I guess
you have to try and he doesn't you
extracting every last chance that you've
got to play F4 I don't know why shark is
not playing a four
Knight D7 no that's a great move 97.
it's too late it's too late that
increment should be enough for dink to
secure it
and E5 is defending C2 still not over E6
E6 oh wait a second Queen D6 check oh
Queen you should save the day Queen D6
saves it because it's coming through
clutch here H5 still trying to check and
it's over it's over it's over
alding needs is a draw and he's going to
get a win and he's going to get the
match incredible oh my goodness and the
same score as yesterday's match and
dingy Ren he all he need to do was hold
in the bullet he did just that he moves
on to the court of funds but what a
match this was done I I mean my head is
spinning my head is spinning as well and
that bullet uh portion not only lived up
to its height but did five times that I
mean I think we both sensed that
something like this was going to happen
but that was I was just holding my
breath the entire time what an
incredible match and what a performance
by diglyran whose consistency whose grit
shows through until the very end he wins
the match insane absolutely amazing and
we are gonna head to a break and get the
players on but before we do we want to
give a shout out to uh the sponsors of
the speed Chess Championship because the
speeches Championship is presented by
coinbase so whether you're looking to
make your first crypto purchase or an
experienced Trader coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess and get
five dollars in Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account we'll be right
back everybody well dingley ran shock
around you will not want to miss their
thoughts on that exciting match
foreign
[Music]
and we are joined by the players thank
you so much to you both for playing an
excellent match uh ding I want to start
with you congratulations and my first
question is you know you haven't played
over the board chess in a long time were
you Rusty before the match or what did
you do to keep in shape to play this
match
uh
although I did not play many overboard
games for one more than one year but I
played many rapid games and many record
tournaments probably them and bullet
it's a very new to me and so I cannot
avoid to being a very nervous people
again since I haven't played bullets for
many times
so before this game I played some one
mid million plus one second in in
chis.com to just get used of this time
control right and I found that the time
is very very short and suddenly I got
into time travel so I just want to avoid
it during the game
um well we thought you did a great job
of it uh
sorry that the match did not go your way
where do you feel like the match slipped
away from you uh what do you think were
the turning points in the match for you
yeah I think it's it was a very good
much conversation for the dink for a
good match
it was very nice games I enjoyed I think
it was a very important moment when I
was in a last game in five minutes was I
and it was very interesting position uh
in last game that I lose and I also in
in all months in last games I mean it
was very strange I mean when it was some
time pressure I don't know I mean okay
we played with much I think many
interesting uh games many interesting
moves and
everything is absolutely okay I mean he
played a little bit better than me
that's for this evening
uh chakra I have a question for you uh
it seemed like you gave time back to
ding when he disconnected that was
extremely nice of you and everyone who
was watching all the fans they were just
giving hearts and showing their thanks
and gratitude for you being such a good
sport so I just want to make that known
and also you know thank you for being
such a really good sport
thank you very much thank you thank you
uh ding uh once again very impressive
games uh is do you have anything any
tournaments uh on the horizon in the
next couple of months
no and there might be some Parliament
advice not sure yet
I think for today uh it seems uh
especially when I was black I defend as
a castle there he tried to break it by
many different ideas
so it's very interesting yeah
yeah and soccer on your end you know
ding often plays very solidly did it
seem like you were having a uh was it
your plan to just try to attack him
because once you started getting
aggressive it felt like the game became
more natural for you and you're playing
some great chess
yeah it was very strange because uh okay
I tried to play in every game in some
different openings but I tried that I
see my every different openings is the
thing is a good better position but he
played every time same opening same idea
it's not easy play you when you think
you you can play every game different
openings but against thing is not
working
it is he's a good developing and he
played I mean pretty much I just want to
play and enjoy from much I know it's I
played against one number two and he's
but okay I mean it was very nice much
really oh maybe I missed some big
moments maybe till the last game it was
I mean I have some chance that's okay
I'm
I I know
all just fancy they enjoy from this one
thanks yeah I'm also happy about my
performance in opening this is since I I
checked your games before the game
before the game so I know you you're
some Sidelines so I got prepared for it
especially something like even foreign
all right there was that one game with
e45 Knight C3 and D4 well the openings
Robert I think were really fascinating
and um just a great match all around uh
congratulations to you ding you have a
tough match coming up with the winner of
aronian versus dubov but uh chakra we of
course hope to see you in the world
lists and Rapid as well so thanks to
both of you for for a fantastic match
thanks
wow what a match that was really a
phenomenal one and I'm just so happy
that we're treated to the spectacle and
watching these two players play the
respect they showed for each other I
mean I'm just glad to have been a part
of it Dania and as you said England
moves on to face the winner of Lavon and
dubov and
should be another excellent match
absolutely I mean every single match in
in the SEC
is is epic and it you know the fact that
both of the first two matches have
finished with the same exact score 14 to
12 and as close as these matches have
been I think speaks volumes about the
skill level of these players and the
kind of entertainment that they produce
when they play a three-hour Blitz and
bullet match
as I said yesterday the speed test
Championship is and I'm biased yes but
it's my favorite tournament to cover and
it is more than living up to its
expectations so far I'm sure it will
continue to do so going into the next
couple of days and can I just reiterate
just how kind both of those two players
oh absolutely I was thinking that too
it's really heartwarming to hear them
like you when I was saying to Shakura
that all of chat was giving him hearts
which we noticed we saw don't you worry
chat we don't always ignore you but they
were so happy to see his sportsmanship
and then ding's phase was like so
appreciative of the fact that Mama jar
did that and was just like genuine
mutual respect and I'm just so happy
that we could showcase those players
because on the board off the board they
are just stellar and it's just fantastic
really well it absolutely is this is not
performative you know it's not
Showmanship it's genuine respect for
each other it's genuine sportsmanship
and that mixed with the competitiveness
that goes on on the board I think makes
these matches absolutely magical
well we have more matches in store
because while this match has come to its
conclusion we get another match tomorrow
and we have Alexei sarna who qualified
through the Grand Prix speeches
Championship qualifier system and then
we have rehard report who is replacing
Ali fuja who withdrew after winning the
grand Swiss and he is going to make his
way to candidates but he will not be
able to win a speeches Championship
report to somebody who you will not want
to miss because he is a fantastic player
he doesn't play all that much relative
to the other top players but it's a
sight to behold I am so happy he's in
the field yeah and let me say let me
tell you sir now is not sleeping any
more peacefully because version has been
replaced with the report he's an
absolute beast and that match is going
to be coming your way tomorrow November
10th at 9 00 a.m Pacific so slightly
later start time mark your calendars
this is going to be one for the ages and
look at the rest of the schedule coming
up because we have a match tomorrow we
have a match on Thursday we have a match
uh two matches on Thursday oh my gosh
you know I forgot about that and then uh
match on Friday and then it continues
the Monday after that so uh everyone
mark this down take a screenshot you
know how to do that you're on the
computer and make sure that you are here
for the speeches presented by coinbase
we do want to thank the sponsors once
more it's so amazing to be able to host
this event year after year and it would
not be possible without coinbase so
really thank you to them and Diana thank
you for joining me on your birthday I
mean what worse way is there to spend
your birthday terrible I mean not only
do I spend it with you that's a single
whammy but the double whammy is that I
watch to amateurs play for three hours
and ding absolutely terrible I had to
get up at 3am but in all seriousness
couldn't think of a better way to spend
my morning so thank you Robert always a
pleasure thank you to all of the fans
and to our outstanding uh production
team for another seamless display this
was awesome certainly was and there's
much more to come tomorrow the speeches
Champion continues for now enjoy the
rest of your day enjoy chess and we'll
see you soon from the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
foreign
[Music]